hey everyone this is Greg uh I believe
this will be hitting your podcast feed
on December
27th uh so first off let me just wish a
belated Merry Christmas to everyone
listening um and I just wanted to give a
brief introduction to the episode you're
about to listen to uh as it is an
atypical episode of the podcast in that
uh it was not originally an episode of
The Stronger by science podcast I I
recently appeared as a guest on the data
driven strength podcast where we chatted
for about 4 hours uh about uh mechanisms
of hypertrophy really getting uh pretty
deep into the weeds so if you need or
just want quite a bit of really nerdy
nitty-gritty audio content to help you
kind of de-stress from the holidays uh
hopefully this will be well received um
and yeah uh also before turning it over
to uh Zack and Josh to to tee up the
actual episode you're about to listen to
um just two quick notes one is that this
episode has already been released in the
data driven strength podcast feed so if
you if you if you already listen to that
podcast and you see it and you're like
oh my God these guys did eight hours of
of content total on this topic uh what
more are they getting into um don't
worry it is the same episode um so if
you already listen to it over there uh
you can you can just skip this one as it
is the exact same content you've already
heard and if you haven't listened to it
uh I think you'll enjoy it and if you do
I would strongly recommend uh checking
out Josh and Zach's podcast the data
driven strength podcast uh they're
they're good guys they do good work and
if you like the stronger by science
podcast and you don't already subscribe
to the data driven strength podcast as
well uh I I think you'd really enjoy it
they're I think on a pretty similar
wavelength to us talking about a lot of
similar topics um with a similar level
of care and depth and Nuance uh so yeah
if if you like if you like rpod I think
would like theirs um go go and uh
subscribe and I hope you enjoy all right
uh with that out of the way I will turn
it over to them and I I hope you enjoy
the
[Music]
show
all right what's going on everyone
welcome to episode 58 of the data driven
strength podcast today is I think a
pretty uh interesting and and unique
episode we have a guest on we don't have
guests super frequently we like to only
Reserve uh these uh highly coveted guest
spots when we think they are uniquely uh
uniquely beneficial to a discussion and
when we think it's it's more than just
you know getting the same folks on to
discuss the the same old things so um
this this will also be the first time we
kind of formally discuss um the uh meta
aggression that Zack LED on proximity
failure for strength and hypert outcomes
which if you're not familiar with the
meta regression uh you're probably going
to get familiar today um so we have Greg
Knuckles on which which I failed to
mention um and
basically it's been interesting from
from our perspective as the as two of of
multiple authors on the Met regression
because the the models that ultimately
were the best fit models in the the
paper have been used to kind of support
multiple different camps which which we
found interesting um and also the
pre-print process it's currently as of
recording this on its second version
It's currently also recently been
submitted to a journal and the the
pre-print process has allowed for some
very fruitful discussions um and one of
which is has especially been the case
with with Greg and we think Greg
provides a very uh helpful and unique
perspective in terms of the
interpretation specifically of the best
fit models that that we we got in our
analyses um so kind of the the way this
will be structured is we'll give an
overview I'll I'll pass it to Greg first
to introduce himself and then I'll I'll
pass it to Zach uh to go ahead and kind
of give an overview of what we did and
then we'll probably get into discussion
a a a general discussion of
interpretation and also potential
mechanisms of hypertrophy and probably a
lot of uncertainty there as well um
we'll probably touch on strength a
little bit but that's probably a little
bit less interesting so uh I will plug
our rpe guide which we
have just updated um so if you're
listening to this that means the RP
guide is now on its version three I
believe the first one we released was in
2021 version 2.0 kind of needed an
update for a while to be honest um but
we kind of waited until this analysis
was done um and the reason I I mentioned
that specifically is if you are
interested in some of the theoretical
rationale for why we think we see the
Practical outcomes that we do for
strength that's a great place to get
hopefully a a relatively straightforward
but also comprehensive overview of how
we think about proximity failure for
strength um so check out that that link
will be in the description on YouTube or
or your podcast player of choice um and
yeah with that Greg thank you for being
here um I I'll kick it to you for a
quick intro I don't think you
necessarily need an introduction I'm
sure most listeners will be uh familiar
with you but let's hear what you got to
say in terms of uh what you do and uh
tell us a little bit about yourself well
thank thanks for having me on guys uh
you you certainly know how to butter a
fella up um my name is Greg uh I have a
website called Stronger by science where
I write about nerdy lifting related
things um powerlifter powerlifting coach
um yeah yeah that's me that's
me that'll do uh you also have the
effective reps article that you wrote
was that
2021 uh man I feel like it I feel like
it was older than that but I'm I'm
honestly not sure who knows it's even
2019 anyway it's it's been a few years
now and I think that article in in other
folks work as well has been very
important for both I think I speak for
for both Zach and I in terms of of
course getting multiple viewpoints and
and uh kind of thinking through you know
like the the analysis that you did Greg
and what other folks have done um so
that's definitely part of the reason why
we uh we value your your perspective
here and looking forward to to uh you
kind of being part of the discussion
here but with that Zack give us a
overview of the Met analysis kind of why
we did it um why it might seemingly be a
little bit different in terms of
outcomes compared to other analyses and
we'll take it from
there sure um so I've had a lot of
practice with this uh kind of elevator
pitch of the method hopefully this is
the the most refined version of it so I
guess the the place to start here is
just kind of the the initial idea though
what we attempted to do and ultimately
how that compares to the other meta
analyses that have been done on this
topic so typically the way that these uh
this area of research is summarized is
kind of through a categorical binary
comparison failure versus non-failure
right and so typically a meta analysis
is going to compare the difference
between those two conditions summarize
those through a procedure or statistical
procedures and ultimately pop out kind
of that summary effect size of the
difference between the two conditions
now ultimately what that
leads to is that you're categorizing a
continuous variable in this case which
is r or proximity to failure um that um
that what we're interested in and so the
the most upto-date meta analysis that um
some people think seem to think is kind
of at odds with with what we've done is
is by Martin refo and colleagues and
that was a really really good meta
analysis where they took things even a
step further and and and categorize
things by failure definition um which is
one of the biggest sources ources of
ambiguity in this area of research and
they did a really nice job um in doing
that and so the the kind of the place we
wanted to to take the next step was go
through some uh procedures to allow us
to explore and I'm going to use the word
explore pretty um specifically the dose
response relationship between proximity
failure and the outcomes of Interest so
ultimately we're trying to get that nice
summary curve of the outcome that we
care about and are our values right and
so
as anyone who's read this body of
research um you know study by study
you're going to quickly realize that the
methods of each study are not um
detailed enough to allow us to do that
um you know right out the box right so
we basically went through a systematic
but inherently subjective um number of
procedures to estimate the r for every
single condition within the these
studies that were included in the
inclusion criteria and ultimately that's
another important thing to bring up is
that our inclusion criteria was
considerably more broad than a lot of
the other met analyses in this area we
basically tried to look for any study
that directly or indirectly manipulated
proximity failure so this included
things like the velocity loss research
alternative set structures um studies
that directly manipulated proximity
failure like the failure non-failure
research and a whole lot more so we
basically try to find every study that
directly or indirectly manipulated
proximity to failure and so at the very
front of this the estimation process
isn't something you kind of have to get
on board with so obviously from a face
vality perspective we wouldn't have done
this if we didn't think we could
estimate it from you know a decent
perspective and I think it it does that
but there is that inherent limitation of
the way that the RS needed to be
estimated so that's that's something to
to note on the front end from there we
basically went through this process to
take the estimated R values and relate
those to the outcome of interest and
kind of explore that dose response curve
we went through the whole gamut of
different ways you could fit these these
models and I think that's something that
doesn't often get talked about is just
the the numerous subjectivities that can
kind of go in this from the version the
first version to the second version We
simplified our modeling procedure and
that ultimately led to marginally
different uh results in terms of what
was the best fitting model and so that's
important to to realize and important to
underline how unstable the quote unquote
best fit model really is and so I think
that's the first piece to kind of let us
know that the the ultimate best fit
relationship shouldn't be taken as like
gospel it's it's an unstable
relationship that gives us a broad
directionality of the way these
adaptations Trend with proximity to
failure but as we'll talk about the over
interpretations of exactly what that
curve look like can lead to some uh
potentially counterintuitive findings um
so like I said we fit a whole bunch of
different shapes linear nonlinear models
and kind of popped out what was the best
fit uh one thing I want to hit on before
we kind of talk about the actual results
is that another thing that doesn't often
get this stuff uh discussed is kind of
the overall quality of these models so
the the overall kind of you know
measures of model quality uh fit were
modest at best so that basically tells
us that in these models proximity to
failure has a modest kind of predictive
quality but it's far from the only thing
that matters and so that's another thing
to very strongly keep in mind is that
yeah we observed some you know in the
case of hypertrophy a quote unquote
meaningful slope um from a statistical
lens but that's not at all saying that
that was a very strong predictive factor
in terms of the actual outcomes observed
um so that's important to keep in mind
and that's reflected in the kind of the
uncertainty intervals and literally
every single estimate throughout the
analysis they're extremely wide they
often go on both sides of zero and that
can lead to some you know potentially
counterintuitive predictions moving
forward as we as we get more data so
that's another thing just to keep in
mind um in in terms of the actual
findings that we found that's a not
right way to say that in terms of the
actual findings um the relationship for
strength and RAR once the percentage of
one RM has been taken out of the
equation is basically null meaning that
independently of load proximity failure
really doesn't seem to influence
strength gains at all whereas for
hypertrophy gains in muscle size tend to
improve as you get closer to failure
that's really that is to me the the the
takeway kind of message um from the from
the analysis rather than you know going
and over interpreting the curve and
comparing the exact effect size from
failure to one R to two R and coming up
with these large mathematical um kind of
calculations on how we should um
optimize proximity of failure I would
really stop at those directional
statements given all the limit
limitations that we've already discussed
finally um we did two other things that
kind of explore things further we looked
at a ton of different interacting
moderators so things like exercise
selection the load use training status
um the intended concentric velocity all
different kinds of things that could
potentially also mediate this
relationship in an interacting fashion
and we'll come back to you know a few of
those that potentially were important um
and then also we looked at um because
there was so little data greater than 10
R kind of the way that regression models
work some of those really far out data
points can kind of have unduly weight on
the overall directionality of the
estimates so we went ahead and fit
additional models where we only use the
data points of 10 R and less and the
thing to note there is that the slopes
basically became less dramatic for both
uh hypertrophy and strength um but the
same patterns um tended to emerge um so
they seem to to hold up when we only
consider the data you know within the
relevant R ranges for the most part um
so yeah that is kind of what we did in
in a broad um fashion of what we found I
guess Josh real quick did I did I miss
anything you think is important um
before we kind of move on to the actual
interpretations and misinterpretations
that kind of were out there upon this
hitting uh hidden the internet I think I
think that was a really overview um I'll
point one thing out that you might have
kind of indirectly said but I think is
is good to help kind of bridge the gap
between this overview here and a
discussion of interpretations or or
potential misinterpretations so the
inclusion criteria specifically for the
analysis was that the studies had to be
volume equated in some way but that gets
tricky with proximity to failure right
because it depends how you you count
volume right or or how you define volume
is it set volume is it rep volume um
because in in practice total training
volume and proximity to failure cannot
necessarily be completely separated
right so the inclusion criteria is that
the study either had to be repe equated
or set equated so let's just quickly
give an example of those so a repeated
study might be eight sets of five for a
protocol compared to four sets of 10
with the same percentage of one rep max
right um so that's not squated but it's
repeated and I think you know that just
kind of passes the sniff test in terms
of okay that's that's a study that
definitely looks at proxim failure so we
had both repeated studies and SE equated
studies a set equated study would be
saying okay I'm going to do three sets
all the way to failure versus another
condition that does three sets to two R
right so those are both kind of getting
at the question of proximity failure but
perhaps through a slightly
different from a slightly different
angle and and the reason I want to bring
those up specifically is I think it also
adds color to the strength findings in
the sense that if it's rep equated or S
equated um they had to be also load
equated right so again load seems to
kind of Drive strength gains at least in
the the short to moderate term I.E the
the length of of time that most training
studies are but for hypertrophy I
think understanding that both types of
volume uh equation if you will led to
kind of similar a a similar relationship
in terms of the relationship between
Proxima to failure and hypertrophy so if
you have only repated studies and you
see that uh conditions that train closer
to failure are Le lead to more
hypertrophy that kind of permits the the
tentative conclusion that reps closer to
failure are inherently more hypertropic
right because the same number of reps at
the same load were performed in both
conditions but one of them had those
same reps at a closer approxim to
failure on the other hand set equated
studies you can make the argument that
if you see greater hypertrophy in the
groups training closer to failure that's
just a result of more volume right so
the reason I bring that up is is you see
relatively a similar relationship if if
again you have if you look at just
repated studies or just set equated
studies but kind of
[Music]
the the the downstream application of
that or the downstream interpretation or
the extrapolations you can make from
that are kind of inherently different
and I think that's worth pointing out
that estimation went into this a
specific inclusion criteria went into
this which um if anything was probably
more broad than than other studies and
the just lack of stability in terms of
the relationships I think is just an
absolutely vital thing for for The
Listener to take home like the the
models that we have are not incompatible
with okay I think there were 26 for
hypertrophy let's say 5 or 10 or 15
years from now there's double that
there's 52 studies they're not
incompatible with a completely different
relationship especially as you know we
get Martin Fall's study with very good
failure definition and very good control
of R um and and and I'm sure that's only
going to improve in the research at
large so hopefully that example is
helpful for The Listener to just
understand and kind of nail home those
points you made Zach about like hey we
see the the general directionality of
the relationship
but it's not something that like hey
this is this is the nail in the cofin
this is exactly how much more hypert you
get with with different RS or or with
different uh you know set end points if
you if you want to clean any of that up
sack let me know but hopefully that's a
a good no that that I think that's a
that's a good place to to kind of wrap
up the the overview there and so I think
that's where we can kind of begin to
discuss the interpretations that have
been out there right um the
the biggest thing that I would say that
I've seen kind of out there that's
potentially been misinterpreted is just
the um kind of directly taking the the
shape of the curve of the first version
of the preprint in particular as you
know the um not not uh incorporating the
instability of the relationship in mind
and ultimately um using this to support
some some popular models that have been
out there to kind of explain um
hypertrophy outcomes when it comes to um
uh proximity of failure and so that
that's probably the biggest one that
we'll hit on in terms of um the the
different explanations of the shape of
the curve some other ones that we've hit
on is the the implications that this is
related to um saying that volume for
doesn't matter or it's somehow in in
support of a low volume two failure
approach I'm not going to spend too much
time on that but the results of the the
moderator analyses quite literally
exactly are oppose that um it would say
that training you know closer to failure
is obviously a positive input for muscle
size but also um additional volume would
also improve um uh uh hypertrophy
outcomes so that I don't think is a
particularly strong um interpretation of
the data and then just the the fact that
there are interacting factors right um
the biggest one that um in the first
version of the preprint was was kind of
a meaningful relationship and all of the
analyses but in the second version was
only in a few was just that of load and
so training with you know heavier loads
doesn't seem to require training as
close to failure for I purch to be you
know quite optimized as training farther
away from failure so I think that's
another um important thing to kind of
consider and the downstream implications
thereof um and then also just a few
other things that based on the inclusion
criteria that Josh laid out there were a
few studies that are commonly kind of
cited in this conversation that weren't
included um one of them kind of mostly
on the kind of the non-failure um
proponent side is is one from Carol and
colleagues that was a concurrent
training study that was not load equated
so it wasn't included but shows a pretty
strong um effect in favor of take uh
stay in a couple reps shy of failure
sometimes a lot of reps shy FR failure
and then one on the other side um is one
from goo and colleagues and that's just
an example where they didn't uh report
the raw data and the authors were
difficult to contact not not from any
fall of their own it just wasn't able to
get the the data from them so there's a
couple cases where certain data wasn't
able to be included um which is another
uh you know limitation of of the of the
study but okay with our scientific uh
jargon and kind of summary out of the
way now we can kind of kick around uh
talk shop here and and kind of talk
about some things that I think are going
to be interesting for the listener and
ultimately get us to reveal the
principles that underly our practical
application which I think is the the
most interesting thing that kind of
comes from this um so I'm I'm going to
come back to the misinterpretations of
the shape of the curve so uh ultimately
the way that this has been kind of
interpreted is kind of what I would say
the Resurgence of the quote unquote
effective reps model and and and
suggesting that um kind of the
the way you can interpret that there's
kind of two versions that Greg you've
like Josh kind of talked about in the
intro you did a really nice uh article
on this topic um that will probably go
through a lot of the kind of the you
know the arguments and and kind of the
discussion related to but there's really
two versions of the effective reps model
and I think we're going to discuss more
of the latter but the first is just that
gains and muscle size tend to benefit
from sets taken closer to failure and I
would say at at Large that's really what
the the the analysis does seem to
support but that's not a
particularly strong or challenging claim
it's just kind of um observing the
directionality of the dose response
relationship which we would tend to
agree with whereas the kind of the
quotequote hard version of effective
reps is that really the last five reps
are the ones that contribute to
hypertrophy given some other uh
conditions so um Greg will actually let
you speak now um what uh when you kind
of saw the the first version of The Met
regression kind of some of the
discussions around this and kind of the
theoretical models it was in support of
or lack thereof what um kind of struck
your eye about it and ultimately um how
does that kind of factor into the way
that you view um these kind of
theories yeah so so just for the
listener um the the reason that I'm the
guest on this podcast I think is that um
when the when the first version of The
Meta regression was published um I saw a
lot of people talking about it and uh
the way that I saw people talking about
it I found very frustrating because it
didn't seem to actually track
particularly well with what even the
first version of The Met regression was
saying um and it was in a way that I
suspect did you guys probably didn't
fully dis or didn't fully agree with
either um so I I started working on an
article about it uh that I that I was
bouncing back and forth uh with Zach and
finally realized like to fully do it
justice um it would have needed to be
way longer than I actually had time to
write so I just kind of scrapped it um
but yeah that that was uh that that's
that's probably why I'm here right now
and a lot of those kind of
misinterpretations of of the initial
meta regression um did have to do with
with the shape of the curve in the
initial met regression and the
interpretations people were drawing from
it um so Zack would would you like to
just for for The Listener kind of
describe the the shape of the Reps and
Reserve versus hypertrophy curve in the
initial meta regression and the
differences like I this this would be
much easier were it a visual medium um
it's it's always great podcast content
to describe graphs but unfortunately I
think it's uh it's unavoidable in this
situation for sure yeah we definitely
optimized for views around here so we're
just going to continue to talk about
graphs all time um so yeah in in the
first version um as as we kind of
discussed we fit a bunch of different
models um but the one that seemed to be
the best fit um which again was a razor
thin Advantage SL win was this linear
log curve that basically shows from zero
to approximately two or three R there's
a relatively sharp decrease and then a
Less Market decrease as you kind of go
throughout the rest of the range of R
and I think you know Greg and self
included both kind of having read the
individual studies that's a little bit
surprising um I think if you go through
all the other meta analyses pretty much
every single summary of effect size does
lean in favor of failure but you know
there's limitations there one of the
studies is a pretty strong outlier um
some other things to consider there but
in general um there does seem to be an
advantage of failure but I think most
people were a little bit interested in
that being the exact shape that
ultimately shuck out as the as the best
fit um in the second version of the
preprint it was linear um and and we
simplified our modeling procedure to
avoid um overfitting basically our our
our number of studies and that
ultimately kind of made things a bit
more conservative um which I think is
good for interpretation but that initial
version which is kind of when our
conversation began Greg was the um the
that linear log curve that basically
shows as you reach you know the last
couple reps to failure there is a
marketing increase in hyper
stimulus yeah yeah so um the the chatter
I saw about that that uh that did tend
to frustrate me quite a bit was
essentially like you alluded to before
folks just interpreting that trend line
as the only finding of the study um and
also kind of like misinterpreting the
trend line itself so to to get into into
that a little bit more um it was it was
it was taken with much Glee by folks uh
promoting what um what you previously
referred to and what I referred to in uh
in the draft of the article that I sent
you as the hard version of the effective
reps model the idea that it is really
just like the last five or so reps in a
set that stimulate
hypertrophy um and so essentially uh if
if you look at kind of the full scatter
plot of results um that the trend line
was trying to model um you see that so
essentially a prediction one would
generate from the hard version of the
effective reps model is at that if you
train with more than five reps in
reserve you will not stimulate any
hypertrophy at all um or like H maybe a
little if someone's completely untrained
but like basically it shouldn't be
effective like you're doing no effective
reps um but I mean like the vast
majority of individual data points with
five plus reps in reserve were still
positive effects like most of them did
find uh you know training at six seven
eight reps in reserve you're still
pretty reliably seeing hypertrophy um
and in fact I think the largest single
effect size in the entire met
progression was at like six reps in
reserve which should be zero effective
reps and therefore completely
ineffective training um and so yeah like
it it seemed like a lot of the
interpretations seemed to ignore um the
data that the model was based on and two
uh you know even that initial linear log
curve the kind of mean model effect uh
for the trend line itself was still very
comfortably above zero uh all the way
out to you know 10 plus reps in reserve
um which again would seem
to uh push back pretty strongly against
the the hard version of the effect of
reps model um and so the the reason I
found it particularly frustrating is it
came across a bit like a m and Bailey AR
argument where in effect like you are
going to promote the hard version of the
effective reps model you say oh like the
the last five reps before failure are
the ones that truly stimulate
hypertrophy for these uh like discrete
mechanisms that that we're going to lay
out and explain to you and like it it
seems um essentially like it's
interesting like were the hard version
of the effective reps model true it
would be like
genuinely uh interesting and tell us
something NE about physiology and
generate useful actionable predictions
um but the meta regression doesn't
really support it um so the the
proponents of the hard version of the
effective reps model kind of went
towards the soft version and they're
like oh look it it looks like these last
few reps before failure do seem to be
quite important for hypertrophy
therefore this supports the effective
reps model and then you know like let's
not let's not talk about the fact that
we are seeing robust hypertrophy in
situations where there should be zero
effective reps and as soon as we've
shared this this graph we're just going
to go straight back to talking about the
hard version of the effective reps model
like the um just to like Define a term
there a Mot and Bailey argument um is
the idea that like there is
a uh like in an interesting audacious
and wrong version of something that you
want to argue for but you know you can't
really support it um so then when you're
kind of in public and and talking to a
more skeptical audience you go towards
um like a more acceptable and it just
kind of like broadly broadly acceptable
version of the argument you're trying to
make like in a way that will go down a
little bit easier
um like uh you know an example is like
if someone was like a a hardcore
libertarian what they might want to
argue for is like oh let's like get rid
of the entire federal government but you
know they're what they might say in
polite Society is like oh we should
lower taxes a little bit uh and then if
folks are like oh yeah yeah I I would
like taxes to be lower they then are
like oh look like all of these people
are also Libertarians like me and also
want to abolish the entire government
you know like that's that's kind of a a
classical example of a mod and Bailey
argument um and like that term comes
from like medieval
architecture essentially like the mot
was like a um kind of like the the large
kind of area around uh a castle that
wasn't all that uh like protectable but
is kind of like the area that a a
principality would like to control and
then the Bailey was like the more
fortified version in the interior so
essentially like when you're challenged
you Retreat to the Bailey like the uh
the more defensible version of some
position but then as soon as the
challenge is gone you go back to the m
kind of the more expansive but less less
defensible thing um and so yeah that's
that's how I saw your met aggression
being used um and I I didn't like it uh
because one I think that's um a little
bit intellectually dishonest uh and two
as someone who's a fan of accurate and
intellectually honest research
interpretation um I didn't think that
your meta regression really did support
the the hard version of the effective
reps model um so yeah yeah that's that's
what what kind of generated my interest
in it
Josh you GNA say something yeah I was
trying to unmute myself but I think we
finally got it can I get can I get
something a little bit off my chest here
um sure
sure so B basically what we saw in in
version one and Zach kind of mentioned
how in version two that has been
submitted for publication the the best
fit model effectively changed but again
we mentioned that the the that just goes
to show that the uh the stability of the
relationship the best fit model is is
not entirely clear but either way uh
what our met aggression generally showed
is that you know that that direct that
directionality in terms of training
closer to failure benefiting
hyper let me make two points the first
is
that I'd say man Zach when we first met
in like
2018 something like that we we we were
definitely counting like effective reps
reps calculator baby yeah um 10 sets of
three at rp9 optimal certified yeah we
we were trying to even worse yet we were
trying to apply it to to strength
training so that was an interesting time
and then I'd say maybe maybe from that
time period 2018 or
so through maybe
20120 is 2021 we kind of swung the other
way specifically talking about
hypertrophy here um I think we were
closer to right at that time um because
but but basically we took a position
that I think kind of resembled like uh
you know like in in the mass research
review for example uh Mike sordos kind
of took the position of like hey hy pery
can be maximized quite far from failure
and we kind of aligned with that I think
a good amount I think we did a good job
at that time emphasizing the importance
of high loads in that sort of
application I think we're really
thinking through the the powerlifting
lens but nonetheless we were definitely
not in we had kind of done a 180 on the
the effective reping for for hypertrophy
um I think with this analysis we we've
probably come to a healthy Middle Ground
I would like to think um so that's the
the first thing to say is that these
results surprised us even from Reading
every single you know individual study
multiple times and and trying to put the
pieces together ourselves and then when
you actually put it in a statistical
model like this you know there are
multiple factors that can again
influence the the best of metal so
that's the first thing I wanted to to
get off my chest the second thing is
that I've seen a lot of people directly
compare it to um one of the figures in
Martin rafal's met analysis um and I'm
having a hard time with this tab on my
computer so I can't tell you the exact
figure number it is but basically what
you see is they have on the x-axis
roughly proximity to failure and then on
the y- axis effect size of of muscle
hypertrophy and you kind of see the
opposite of version one of our um of our
met
aggression and people kind of put up the
the two figures side by side right
Martin's kind of showed that or or
seemed to show that okay you see greater
hypertrophy and then it kind of
plateaus as you get closer to failure
it's figure five in that paper figure
five thank you thank you for the assist
um but that that was a a conceptual
figure if I recall correctly based on
kind of some more categorical type of
variables I think they plan to do a sort
of met aggression um and I don't think
they ended up doing it um but anyway
that wasn't necessarily A A met
aggression it was kind of a a grouping
of General categories of closer to
failure based on failure definitions and
then further from failure I think based
on like some of the Velocity law stuff
the x-axis isn't scaled using interval
data it's categorical yeah exactly
exactly so while the
the the those figures right figure five
versus our main model are seemingly the
opposite the result the the the the
analyses were inherently different and I
I think that's just something that I've
kind of seen so many times and I I don't
think it's a an accurate representation
of how the the two analyses can kind of
work together right um I think Martin's
paper was awesome uh Zach I think the
paper that you led was awesome I think
there're just different approaches and
we wanted to explore the continuous
relationship between proximity to
failure or R um taking some Liberties in
terms of doing our best to estimate the
r of each study um to try to get an idea
of the the general
relationship so all that's to say
is we were we were surprised by what we
saw um but it's also not incompatible
with some of our our thinking
beforehand um and Zach obviously you've
been a little bit more uh in the weeds
with kind of comparing it to to Martin
stuff so I'm not sure if you have any
followups there yeah no I mean it's that
was an extremely common comparison and I
think ultimately the
the best word to describe like you said
is kind of conceptual like I think what
they did was quite literally the best
they could have done with their with the
data that they had like I think that was
a really honestly I thought that when I
first saw it I thought it was like a
really clever way to kind of get at it
given what they had to operate with but
unfortunately the inherent limitation is
that without quantifying the actual R
each one of those conditions that fell
within each one of those buckets like
Greg said it's the difference between
and categorical like you can't
necessarily Place those on the the xais
in a perfectly ordered fashion because
you haven't actually quantifi the r
values there um so you know just as an
example the velocity loss research
depending on the load utilized can
completely change the r associated with
a given velocity loss threshold so just
placing those um base on the percentage
velocity loss on that axis isn't totally
accurate and I'm not saying what they
did was a bad approach again honestly I
think it's pretty clever way to get at
it but you would need to directly
quantify the r with each one of those
conditions just as that as one of the
examples another example is within the
non-failure um kind of bucket obviously
there's a range of rears that went into
that so some of the ones that were
contributing to the effect size could
have been on the way closer end to the
to the momentary failure end of the
spectrum and other on could have been
way farther away that could have
basically led to an entirely different
conceptual shape which is exactly what
we tried to follow it up with basically
right that's like the the way that our
piece fits in so so yeah I think that
was um that's a good uh thing to mention
like they aren't at odds with one
another at all in my opinion it's just a
different number of studies a completely
different statistical technique and we
took a ton of subjective but systematic
Liberties to try to do what we did so I
think that's the the the correct thing
there but okay with that out of the
way so I think I think it's uh probably
good to to kind of mention why some of
these models
get so latched on to in the first place
and and people people want to know what
is the best way to predict hypertrophy
outcomes right like that that is what
people want to know and so I think over
the years you know the the kind of the
evolution of how people have tried to
track training volume or probably better
um Quantified as like the stimulus for
muscle growth has been shifted over time
and I know Greg one of the the older
articles on your site but honestly is
pretty common place at this point was
the I forget the the actual author's
name that um uh basically brought the
hard sets um kind
ofon
yes okay there we go I just want to make
sure he gets his
credit so that that was that was you
know that's been pushed as kind of
probably to the stock standard kind of
approach to to count training volume now
and it's shifted from you know the waren
bomb meta analysis from however long ago
when they were counting total
repetitions and now counting hard sets
is kind of the stock standard practice
and you know a Savvy individual
particularly I think those that come
from a mixed goal kind of interest
whether that be powerlifting or like
power building or whatever you have
where you are completing some sets of
less than five reps I think that's where
you kind of get that conceptual like ah
this doesn't seem like we can just count
all sets the same right like we need to
um you know have some sort of a more
granular explanation of how to count
these uh sets also if I'm not taking all
my sets to failure how does that impact
things Etc and so I think that is a
charitable case from where this came
from and I think it's a natural
extension of that desire to have a good
predictive uh people like numbers that
that that nice neat uh metric that you
can track in a spreadsheet to to proxy
the hypertrophy stimulus and I think
that's what's led to the prevalence and
the um the uh yeah prevalence is just
the best word of the effective reps
model in the first place I think it
provides a in in theory or in concept
it's the next evolution of hard sets in
in in at its at a uh at a charitable
presentation of what it's attempting to
do and so I guess that's where we can go
from there is ultimately
defining what that model would um use as
its kind of underlying premises and then
ultimately potentially we can go through
each one of those and talk about you
know areas where we may agree are areas
where we may disagree and then we can
kind of come out the other side and then
see if we can use that kind of
conversation to drive maybe a putting
forth a a different perspective and
ultimately how that's going to drive our
practical applications so with that
unless you guys have anything else to
say I think we can kind of go through
Greg maybe presenting your
interpretation of what the the hard
effective reps model obviously we talked
about kind of the practically facing uh
what it entails but I guess maybe more
of the premise premise conclusion kind
of uh oriented um approach to it so if
you guys have anything else let me know
but that's kind of the direction I think
makes sense yeah I I did I did just want
to add a couple things I think um one is
is that when it comes to people looking
for for variables like something easily
trackable to predict hypertrophy
outcomes there's a there there is a long
history of that um like you mentioned
you mentioned hard sets um but like
plenty of things came before that like
there there was the uh the time under
tension craze back in the day um there
was volume load which was used as kind
of like the standard thing that you
would quantify in the research up
to God probably like 2012 or so um like
I I might like I'm I'm not that old but
I might be revealing how long I've been
following this stuff um there was a
there was an acute muscle protein
synthesis paper by
bird um where so it it used to be
thought that both like uh intensity like
like so back in the day people thought
oh like you you need to be above a
certain intensity threshold like defined
in terms of percent of 1 RM um and like
volume load is really important and so
basically the idea was like you need to
be above at least at least like 60% of
one RM give or take um and beyond that
volume load is like super important and
there was
uh muscle protein synthesis paper by
bird I think in
2012 where um they compared like sets
sets to failure with like 90% And 30% of
1 RM on knee extensions or something
like that and I think they found similar
muscle protein synthesis uh following
both of those interventions um which one
was surprising to the folks who thought
that volume load was super important
because obviously people did way way
more reps with 30% of 1 RM volume load
was higher and was like pretty
surprising to the people that thought
that there was a relatively high
intensity threshold you needed to clear
because 30% seemed like it it did as
well as
90% um and then but folks were like Ah
that's just a cute data and then they
followed it up with a longitudinal study
comparing 30% versus
80% um and is still like pretty big
differences in volume load uh above and
below that kind of like classical 60%
intensity threshold found similar
hypertrophy and so that that kind of
like opened the door to more things but
yeah I mean number of sets number of
reps uh time under tension volume load
now effective reps like there there has
been a pretty a pretty long history of
people looking for just kind of like
single number metrics that they could
use to um like serve as a proxy for the
hypertrophy stimulus that someone is
going to achieve following a particular
workout and I do I do think a lot of
that just comes
from kind of a the natural human desire
for closure and uh lack of comfort with
the UN known um which for the most part
I'm like totally chill with like that's
uh like that that's like that that's
just a normal part of being alive um and
it serves a purpose you know like if you
stop and think about it like you don't
understand hardly anything happening to
you in your life um one of my buddies uh
G bin shout out G from Ireland really
really good dude um one of the things
that he said that he does like if he
feels like someone is bullshitting him
is he just asks them why seven times
like if if someone says like oh like
this is something that's going on oh
that's cool like why is that and they
offer an explanation it's like oh that's
interesting like why is that like
explain it a little bit more and you
kind of for for almost everything you
believe if you take that not even like
seven steps down but like three or four
steps down you you begin to realize like
oh wait like there I'm just going
through life with a lot of like
assumptions that may be bad assumptions
I don't know if they're supported or not
but like if I if I tried to like really
figure out everything I never get
anything done you know like you you need
a certain feeling of certainty to
progress through life and get anything
done and not become a complete basket
case
but why that frustrates me a little bit
in this context is like if if I were to
see a a gy bro like this isn't an if I
see this all the time if uh if someone
you know they're just like a trainer or
they're a lifter or whatever and they're
they're still on the um they're still on
the time under tension train they're
like oh yeah like this is like super
important like this is the only thing
that matters like I don't care um like I
really and truly do not care because
because like just to skip ahead a little
bit I don't think that there's any
single number metric that you could use
to to like pretty accurately predict the
hypertrophy stimulus you're going to get
from a workout I don't know if there
ever will be one but if there ever will
be one I don't think we're particularly
close to knowing what it is like I think
at this point the best we can do is just
get like an extremely rough
approximation um but yeah like you know
if someone is is like non-academic and
and they're just looking like they can
believe whatever they want like I truly
don't care where it gets under my skin
is
when something like that is presented as
like scientific or like quote unquote
evidence-based or based on the research
or based on the literature and is put
forth with an undue degree of confidence
because like the whole point of research
and science is to approach things from a
perspective of epistemic humility and to
approach things from a perspective of
lacking confidence like you don't know
things which is why you're applying the
scientific method and investigating
things further and like fund
fundamentally you're looking for
questions like a a definitive answer a
not many of them exist and
B generally when you think one does
exist it one gets you a Nobel Prize and
two you find out 20 years later it's not
actually a full answer you know like uh
like general relativity you know
like that that seemed to be like the
answer to
gravitation um and like you know
Einstein is remembered and will be
remembered forever for that it's like
okay like we we have an answer now we've
been asking asking questions about this
for so long like since Newton and before
like now we have the answer and this is
incredible um and that was both like
cool and also kind of like well damn
like this is kind of boring like
cosmology seems to be solved now and
then you find like quantum mechanics 20
years later and it's like oh now
there's way more unexplained stuff and
it and this doesn't seem to mesh with
like uh general relativity all that well
so like oo more questions to ask let's
spend 30 billion
on CERN and now now those people are are
wanting an even bigger particle
accelerator they're like cern's not big
enough like we're so close to finding
dark matter we just need to mash
particles together even harder uh very
cool stuff but anyway like that's that's
how science is like supposed to work and
like evidence-based thinking is supposed
to work you know you're you're supposed
to try to learn what we currently know
and instead of taking that and putting a
bow on it and saying okay like we have
the answers like why even do more
research on this stuff like we we know
that this is like the thing that's
causing hypertrophy we have the metric
we can quantify um there there should be
kind of at the heart of that
a uh a comfort with uncertainty uh and
if anything a desire for uncertainty
because that's what Spurs you to asking
more questions and learning more and
expanding human knowledge and so I I do
resent to some extent um any sort of a
thing like presenting itself as like
science communication or like
evidence-based
recommendations that instead of like
attempting to ask more questions and
Inspire
curiosity um instead like trying to
close off a road and saying hey no like
you you you don't really need to ask
more questions because do have the
answers here already um and that is
especially the
case like in an instance like this where
there are still like so many open
questions um and so yeah uh that may may
have been a little bit rambly but
uh yeah hope hopefully there was
something useful there but yeah I I I
think that that fundamentally people
want to be able to quantify this stuff
because they want closure but I think if
you're Pres presenting yourself as like
a science Communicator like an
evidence-based practitioner um closure
shouldn't really be what you're after
like you you shouldn't be you should be
looking for the tenative answers that we
can draw now but like ultimately you
should be looking for the next question
yeah I think there's a a a positive
relationship in terms of uh degree of
direct involvement with a project and
the level of uncertainty by which
the uh findings or conclusions or
interpretation are
communicated um you know I'll just just
using the Met regressions that in
question here right I think some folks
spoke with a lot of certainty regarding
the the application and then you know
you listen to Zach on on revive stronger
whatever the case may be there is an
increase in terms of uh the the level of
uncertainty and you know go f uh sorry
rewind to that time period in in 2018
when we were kind of probably looking
for for that closure that you mentioned
Greg um that was a little bit before you
know Zach and I got experience putting
the the gel on the ultrasound probe and
you know having subjects come in and you
hear on on podcasts like this about you
know people going through breakups
during training studies
um or their dog dying right and you're
like ah yeah that's like a a one-off
example and then you know you you you're
involved in a few training studies
you're like oh that actually happens
right and you know thinking about some
of the within subjects research that
we've either recently completed and and
we kind of be out soon that we're
currently in progress of you know you
see you're with these subjects multiple
times a week and and you
see some folks grow like a weed some
folks grow like a weed in in one leg
some folks grow like a weed in in the
other leg um some folks don't grow at
all right and it
just it's it's honestly been I think a
challenge uh to to be transparent for
for Zach and I kind of going
through that outside looking in period
when we initially started to talk about
research on the internet in some form
and probably having higher confidence in
things because you still need to train
right and you still need to to make
calls
and you probably need to have some
degree of conviction to make it at least
somewhat interesting um I think there's
a probably a subset of of folks that uh
hopefully some of them have found this
show because I think we we try to put
the puzzle pieces together as opposed to
telling you what the puzzle pieces are
and where they go
um so I I think that's that's worth
internalizing for the for the listeners
just yeah that the the complexity of
the physiology the complexity of
research and especially with hypertrophy
this is something that Zach and I were
talking about earlier today actually is
like I think from a coaching perspective
I almost feel like the the the
individual level uh kind of puzzle is
more complicated for strength but for
from a research perspective the number
of
unknowns is higher for hypertophy part
of that's just due to like number of
studies um you you could do a 1rm in in
the 70s right and and report that data
whereas uh methodology for for measuring
hypertrophy has only improved
so I think our interest from a research
perspective have kind of leaned on the
hypertrophy side recently because of a
lot of that uncertainty a lot of those
unknowns
and that's that's not that that that
uncertainty isn't going to go anywhere
anytime soon yeah we we'll we'll try our
best through our uh we we we do our best
to have some degree of St statistical
power but it's it's uh it's still far
off from from anything to make clear
conclusions even when you put all the
research together in a in a continuous
analysis like Zach did
here yeah well and I mean I I think that
the research as it exists
does uh invite and I would say
necessitate a high degree of uncertainty
especially around this topic like just
to get back to it a little bit I mean
like God damn dude like the the
prediction intervals for this model like
you you take you take all of the data on
this topic that exists you put it into a
single meta regression model and you
have prediction intervals um that like
at zero R span from like negative 1%
change in muscle size to plus 20 you
know like if if you if you can look at
those prediction intervals and be like
yes I'm like gotta figure it out I'm
incredibly confident about the precise
relationship yeah between proximity to
failure and hypertrophy I don't know
what to tell you like I I don't think
we're looking at the same data and if we
are I don't think you know how to read a
graph like
that's you know like and that that is
kind of the state of the literature
broadly um uh outcome data like outcome
data doesn't tend to be like super super
clean and have like super clear answers
and as I think we're about to talk about
um there's still like so many open
questions with mechanistic stuff that
it's it's truly wild and I I don't think
people like know or appreciate that and
a lot of that is is in part due to the
fact that like you know when when we
talk about mechanisms of hypertrophy um
we're talking about things that are
happening in Dynamic cells in living
creatures that a lot of things like you
you can't investigate a lot of things
unless you were to remove tissue and be
able to kind of like separate out
proteins look at it under an electron
microscope whatever but then once you've
removed that tissue it's not in the
dynamic living thing anymore and so you
can get kind of that snapshot but you
can't you can't observe how that single
piece of tissue changes over time and
like what precisely is causing those
changes just just as an analogy here um
Greg not to cut you off that I think a
little bit uh this was a good example to
me to just like put some caution on a
lot of the the physiology stuff because
I think anybody that gets into research
initially I think you go through this
kind of dynamic um kind of curve of what
you're interested in like oh this all
this physiology stuff definitely relates
to longitudinal outcomes I'm going to
know the physiology like the back of my
hand that's going to definitely predict
how all this stuff works okay muscle
protein synthesis is maximized in these
conditions therefore that's going to be
the best for hypertrophy get to the
metanalysis of longitudinal outcomes and
not even remotely the same a lot of the
time as the the the mechanistic stuff
right and I think one of the examples
that people will probably be familiar
with that they can kind of lash on to as
an example here is a lot of the fiber
type stuff so I think if you listen
to Dr Andy Galpin talked about this who
is probably the the foremost uh you know
fiber type kind of of uh expert that
people are probably familiar
with and and and following that line of
research I think is really informative
just to understand that hey you know you
got sports commentators on ESPN talking
about fast twitch slow twitch and kind
of are familiar with that parlance but
then you get all the way down to kind of
keeping up to date with like how little
we actually know about how to
appropriately type a fiber how can be
different ac across the longitudinal
nature of that fiber we have um the
actual techniques associated with with
typing a fiber and its myos and heavy
chain uh content is basically mashing up
an entire group of fibers and grossly
assigning um you know a fiber type value
to those like there's just so many
limitations to actually saying within a
human being that this portion of a
muscle fiber located in your quad at
this exact position is this exact
phenotype like that's impossible and but
you hear a lot of people talk
confidently about different changes to
that to that uh that outcome and things
like that whereas the exact methods and
if you listen to somebody who does that
research of counting fibers staining
fibers taking fibers out of a out of a
muscle and Performing all these analyses
it is messy and it is not even remotely
super duper clean so I think you know
that that just like that concept and and
when I when I reference like the people
about ESPN the reason I say that is
because theoretically that's been one of
the very foundational concepts of muscle
physiology is we got the white fibers we
got the red fibers and every textbook
you know is going to start with that
kind of General gross classification so
theoretically you would assume we got
this concept figured out man like we got
Bedrock stuff that got has the these
methods absolutely fine-tuned we know
exactly how all this works when that
couldn't be further from the case so
take on top of that dynamic system
longitudinally adapting to some sort of
stimulus that we can't even quantify as
we've already mentioned now we're now
we're seven steps are moved of things
we're comfortable quantifying and
understanding every single input into
the system so I think that's just a
conceptual example for me that keeps us
you know like like you said with a sense
of humility to understand where we're at
with understanding some of this stuff
Greg already mentioned basically the
only way that we can study a lot of
these mechanisms is removing the out of
the dynamic system in the first place
which is going to have a ton of
different feedback mechanisms to
counteract maybe some of these things
we're observing um out of the body right
so that's that's just another primer to
say like hey man if if you think we got
it all figured out I don't know if I
tend to agree well and even just for a
more direct example here I mean like if
if we were interested in cellular
mechanisms we'd probably remove uh a
small batch of fibers and uh homogenize
it in some way try to extract RNA or
like a certain protein fraction or like
who knows whatever um but like you know
you're you're you're looking at at
mechanisms and adaptations and like a
relatively small number of fibers um and
you might relate that to uh fiber
hypertrophy over the course of like a
12-week study but like fiber hypertrophy
and whole muscle hypertrophy are poorly
correlated for unknown reason
yeah that's another thing like you can't
measure that same fiber twice right like
that that's like another thing I kind
think people don't actually think about
is you biopsy an area you're removing
that tissue anyone wants to get really
sad go to
uh a paper from Cody h a critical
evaluation of biological construct
skeleton muscle Hy size matters but so
does the measurement go to table two
yeah that that's exactly what I had in
mind look look at look at the
relationship and then just uh yeah come
come back and and tell me ex you're
creating more black pill bills on here
man man like sometimes I read that paper
and I just get like so excited about
muscle physiology some sometimes I read
that paper and I'm just like I just want
to like throw everything in the air so
anyway continue Greg um yeah I think I
think that's that's about all I had to
say on that uh actually I don't know I
do have one one more like slightly
cynical thing to say before before we
get into this um I I do think that kind
of
the the popularity of more simplistic
models for muscle
hypertrophy um I I I think that there's
a reason for that like I I think that
there's a reason that um I think there
are several reasons that kind of our
perspective of just like hey this shit's
like very complex and
if we can know anything we have to know
it very tentatively and there's still so
much uncertainty so many open questions
um I think that there are some good
reasons why that's not the popular uh
the popular thing getting out there um
one is that you kind of have to hold
someone's attention for a long time to
make them sufficiently uncertain um
because like again it is just kind of
like a default thing that people like
closure they like certainty and um you
know to like this this is going to be a
pretty long podcast episode and I'm
going to have a lot of things to say
about open questions related to
mechanisms of hypertrophy um and you
know I think you have you have like
smart uh very with it listeners yes I'm
pandering right now um that that would
be open to that but you know the typical
like if you go to just a standard
commercial gym you're not going to find
many data driven strength podcast
listeners
and I I think there's a reason for that
you know it's not it's not that it's not
good content it's that um you know
people people oftentimes are seeking out
information to make them more sure and
confident about what they're doing and
so if you're trying to be more rigorous
and throw some water on
that a minority of people are wired to
like and appreciate that and the
majority of people aren't um and so
therefore uh whe whether intentional or
not um for for the people kind of like
putting forth and promoting these ideas
it does tend to be more profitable to uh
to go with kind of the more simplistic
dumb down to the point of being wrong uh
ideas just because like it's it's going
to connect easier with people one
because it takes less time to
communicate like you only need to hold
someone's attention for three minutes to
communicate like a really simplistic
idea to them um and two like it will
increase their confidence rather than
decrease their confidence you increase
their confidence they're like oh this
must be an expert because they they made
me feel good and I like listening to
people that make me feel good and
fulfill my psychological need for
closure um and so yeah like whether
whether intentionally or not um
um there there are kind of those like
social
forces
um uh incentivizing more more simplistic
ideas and and helping them like go viral
get big get popular um like a a great
example of this would be the idea of
like the carbohydrate insulin model of
weight gain and obesity um like very few
actual serious researchers uh like
looking
into yeah like the Obesity epidemic and
like factors contributing to overeating
and appetite regulation and all of that
blah blah blah you're you're going to
find extremely few of them that buy into
the carbohydrate insulin model um but it
is extremely popular uh just kind of in
in broader Fitness culture uh in part
because it's it's very simple and easy
to understand like you can give someone
a 30second elevator pitch for
carbohydrate insulin model um but if you
wanted to talk about kind of like bioc
psychosocial influences uh like
affecting desire to eat and the
relationship between desire to eat an
actual eating behavior um and how that
interacts with like uh exercise and how
exercise interacts with like total
energy expenditure because like you know
uh then you're getting into the idea of
like added versus constrain models of
energy expenditure and then how that
also interacts with energy balance and
like it if you're trying to like be
accurate and not like super simplistic
it gets very complicated very quick and
yeah like you you can't really give a
30- second elevator pitch for
physiological regulation of of eating
behavior and weight control but you can
for carbohydrate insulin model and so
one of them gets way more popular than
the other um
and so I think I think that something
similar uh might be going on here um so
yeah let's let's get into it I I feel
like that's uh I was going to say enough
wind up probably too much wind up but it
is what it is just the r you guys have
listened to the stronger by science
podcast you you knew what you were
getting into when you invited me on
spine version two baby let's go let's do
it hell
yeah um cool
I think I can can lead us into the next
area here Josh unless you have something
to say I can't tell you're pause okay
cool okay so yeah let's go ahead and
discuss the the kind of like I said the
the potentially underlying premises that
lead up to the ultimate practical facing
model of the quote unquote hard version
of effective reps where the last five
reps are the ones that contribute
hypertrophy I think I'll run through
the as I understand it and you guys can
correct me where I'm wrong the kind of
mechanistic rationale of it and then we
can dive
into support not support kind of go with
go through those Point by point so as I
understand it the idea of the the quote
unquote hard effective reps model are as
follows the basically necessary
conditions for Meaningful amounts of
hypersphere to our occur are a few
things one is going to be near maximal
or maximal motor unit recruitment two
would be a slow involuntary contraction
velocity so basically despite maximal
effort to move the Implement as fast as
possible the contraction velocity is
slow and three that you accumulating
enough of that to reach the sufficient
dosage of meaningful hypertrophy to
occur so you know the maybe only doing
one rep um that's slow is not going to
be a sufficient dosage maybe you got to
get a sufficient dosage there and
they're defining the actual practical uh
the Practical threshold of what you're
observing to meet those conditions is
the last five Set uh reps to a set to
failure so those are the those are the
repetitions that are meeting those uh
conditions with the assumption that when
those conditions are met
that is when a high mechanical tensile
force is being applied to each one of
those recruited fibers particularly um
controlled by the highest threshold
motor units which are going to control
theoretically the fibers that are going
to be the most prop uh have the highest
propensity uh for growth and that is
what is going to lead to the predictions
um that we'll see in the longitudinal
hyper research just as a basic example
that I think is a good example to be
charitable show where this this model
would have a correct prediction with
with to be clear the the idea that
mechanical tension is um for all intents
and purposes the only variable here
that's like actually like directly and
causatively stimulating hypertrophy sure
and and just as a basic example again
we'll get in the nuances of this example
but one practically facing example this
seems to succeed is if we take three
sets to failure twice a week with 80% of
one run and three sets twice a week with
30% of one RM each of those are
accumulating those five effective reps
at each one of those sets and that is
going to help predict that hypertrophy
stimulus ultimately hard sets does that
as well but the you know the advantage
here is if we start factoring in
different RS then that may better
predict differences and outcomes in
theory um okay that's my kind of best
pitch anything that I'm missing there in
terms of the underlying kind of premises
that lead to the Practical endpoint
I I think that Nails
it yeah th thumbs up for me um I mean we
we kind of or or Zach you just kind of
outlined getting to that point of high
per fiber mechanical tension um and I
think where where it might be worth
going next
is there
is that that's all well and good right
but there are multiple steps that are
required to to go from that point to an
actual increase in in muscle size Josh
one thing detail the difference real
quick between at least the way we
generally describe it the difference
between whole muscle and per fiber Force
whole muscle and per fiber Force yeah so
if you think about the the basic force
velocity relationship um basically your
ability to produce maximal force is
highest at slow contraction velocity so
um this is best represented with a
single contraction if you're talking
about whole muscle Force right so your
Force production is going to be highest
with a with 100% a very slow uh single
on the squat for example right and then
it's going to be lower with
50% things get interesting though when
you start to differentiate between whole
muscle forces and per fiber forces
across a a multi-repetition set right um
so if you just think about the force
velocity relationship on the whole
muscle level across multiple
repetitions if if you take a literal
interpretation of that force velocity
relationship basically your conclusion
would be that the highest forces are at
the end of a set but then you just take
a step back and and you think about it
for a second you're like that just
doesn't make sense it doesn't make sense
why whole muscle forces would be the
highest when you've just done a bunch of
reps that are fatiguing you but the
important differentiation here is the
difference between again whole muscle
forces and per fiber forces so if you're
using I think the the best way to
illustrate this is a a pretty long set
right
so uh earlier in that multi-repetition
Set uh whole muscle Force capacity is
the highest but only some muscle fibers
are going to kind of be in the game and
then through a concept called motor unit
cycling eventually as some fibers
theoretically kind of fatigue out or no
longer are contributing to a High degree
to force output um the per fiber uh
forces can be quite High near the end of
the set even though whole muscle force
is theoretically at its lowest
throughout the set and then if you think
about that force velocity relationship
on the per fiber level you can say okay
the contraction velocity is the slowest
um on a fiber level near the end of the
set and thus the force on a per fiber
level is the highest and thus the
tensile stimulus is the greatest with
closer proxim to failure right yeah and
that would be that would be basically
the the Assumption of the model is that
basically all all I wanted to clear
up yeah exactly it is uh all the only
thing I wanted to clear up there is that
it can just be confusing if you think
about force on the whole muscle level
you know Force equals masstimes
acceleration versus what's happening on
the fiber level and those are just two
distinct Concepts I think for the rest
of the kind of chat here we'll probably
mostly focus on the the per fiber level
force and whether or not that that kind
of line of reasoning actually holds up
um at the end of the set so okay with
that Greg I will kick it over to you I
think
the the spot of the conversation that I
think we can we can get started on here
is kind of the caveat that you mentioned
is that seems to be
a additional premise here that the
mechanical stimulus is really the only
directly causitive factor of hypertrophy
and from from uh you know what we've
discussed it seems like that's where you
may have uh you know some some things to
bring up
initially yeah yeah I do um so first
let's let's take like 45 steps back and
ask what does it even mean for something
to be a directly causitive factor for
hypertrophy or just kind of like a a
mechanism of hypertrophy as as people
kind of typically think about it um and
I I think I think a lot of the uh appeal
of the effective reps model and a lot of
the confusion that might be generated
does have to do largely with how people
how like people out there on social
media might think about this stuff
versus how like a scientist would think
about it and how these things are like
discussed in the literature um and so I
think I think basically um if someone
were to say that like uh tension is a
directly causitive factor or a mechanism
of hypertrophy the idea is essentially
like it's a pretty straightforward A to
B to C relationship you generate
sufficiently high tension with a fiber
um that is going to directly stimulate
muscle protein synthesis you do that
over a period of weeks and months and
that muscle protein synthesis
accumulates and eventually results in
muscle growth like it's a pretty simple
A to B to C relationship you have the
stimulus which is tension you have the
acute outcome which is muscle protein
synthesis and then you have the
longitudinal outcome which is muscle
growth and that is
um to to some extent true but also
woefully incomplete um so what's
actually happening uh and how tension
contributes to
hypertrophy um is that tension is sensed
by some sort of mechanosensitive
structure which we're still not even
sure what what those actual like
mechanosensitive structures are that
feel the tension to then like transduce
it into some sort of signaling cast
casade that ultimately results in muscle
protein synthesis but there there are
some like candidate uh proteins that
that might be those actual
mechanosensitive structures um and so
essentially they would sense um tension
uh in a way that like the tension
generated by the muscle fiber would
change the conation of that protein in
some way um probably in some way that
that would kind of reveal a binding site
that wouldn't be revealed otherwise so
then other proteins can kind of like get
in there and interact with that
mechanosensitive protein um it's
probably some sort of kinas which would
mean that it would phosphorate
Downstream proteins phosphorate a
protein change its structure and
function now it can do other stuff that
it wouldn't otherwise like it's kind of
a secondary messenger system um and so
then those proteins that interact with
the mechanosensitive proteins probably
get phosphorated and then they can go
interact with other proteins uh and
there's like six or seven that that are
probably progressing along in a line
until you eventually get to mtor or mtor
C1 um which is kind of at the center of
the classical hypertrophy signaling
Cascade you have things that are
Upstream from it uh that affect proteins
that eventually all interact with mtor
it kind of like Ates and like tries to
interpret those like Upstream signals
and like I'm giving like agency to it
but like you know it's it's a protein
it's it has no intelligence it's just
kind of interacting with the proteins
that are interacting with it um and then
based on kind of the sum total of of the
um like inhibitory and stimulatory
signals that that the mtor signaling
complex is receiving it will then uh
phosphorate Downstream proteins that
then interact with other proteins you
have another like six seven 12 steps uh
and eventually um that results in uh
some sort of effect on myogenic
regulatory factors that affect gene
expression um and so then gene
expression like you're you're reading
genes you're creating messenger RNA that
is going to code for the various
proteins that uh the signal that that
was created by the stimulus that was
kind of transduced through this entire
signaling Cascade um you know eventually
the message that is received is we need
to create some proteins to to do
something um so then the genes are red
creates messenger RNA to code for those
various proteins including the
contractile proteins that primarily
contribute to
hypertrophy um and then that messenger
RNA needs to be
translated by ribosomes which is kind of
like another Factor because ribosome
density can vary um the translational
capacity and like translational
efficiency of each ribosome uh can also
vary but you know that's kind of like
the last step of acute stuff and hey now
you've you've generated some proteins um
and
then uh over time hopefully you you
accrete enough proteins that uh that
measurable hypertrophy occurs but you
know it it's not just kind of like
tension is sensed and then just kind of
directly you you start synthesizing
proteins there's like like dozens of of
steps of kind of like feedback and
regulation at all steps in that process
that could either amplify the signal
created by that tension stimulus or
dampen the T the signal created by that
tension stimulus um and and just like a
variety of things that could ultimately
like cause that stimulus to result in
that accretion of protein or really not
much change in protein um and so yeah
like there are like multiple other in
inputs that influence all stages of that
process and what I described like is
still like massively over simplified uh
so like for instance that that what I
walked you through is kind of like the
classical inor dependent signaling
Cascade but there are also like mtor
independent signaling Cascades um that
that can influence uh muscle protein
synthesis uh there's regulation of gene
expression by epigenetic modifications
that will ultimately influence kind of
like once the signal gets all the way to
the nucleus and you're saying hey let's
let's do some Gene transcription that's
going to affect how accessible those
genes are to be read and ultimately
result in messenger RNA um there are
bioenergetic considerations and
substrate availability to think about um
satellite Cell Activation myonuclear
accretion kind of the translational
capacity of the cell uh ultimately if if
you're getting a bunch of myogenic
regulatory factors saying hey we need to
make a bunch of proteins but you have
kind of a finite number of nuclei that
they're trying to knock on the door and
say hey let me in I need to transcribe
some of your genes like that that could
affect how much uh messenger RNA you end
up creating like I mentioned there's
like ribosome related factors what is
your ribosome density what is the
translational efficiency or or yeah
translation translational efficiency of
of each ribosome um like it's and like
that's still just scratching the surface
like th those are all
factors that go into it so like
ultimately I would argue that nothing
causes hypertrophy kind of in the
classical sense that people think about
causation um you know like if you think
about it in sort of
a like simplified physics problem like
if you uh hit a q ball with a pool stick
uh the the force that the that the pool
stick exerted on the Q ball causes the Q
ball to roll it hits another ball it
transfers force that causes the other
ball to shoot off in a certain direction
at a certain velocity like that's kind
of how we like we we often think about
causation is kind of like strict um
mechanical processes like that with very
few additional inputs influencing them
like it's very A to B to C to D um but
in a like massively complex biological
system like the human body or like a
muscle cell um there's just so much else
going on so like when we think about a a
stimulus for hypertrophy like you you
shouldn't I think really call it like a
cause um or like a mechanism in kind of
the classical sense more so it's it's
just an initiator or regulator of
massively complex biochemical processes
that aren't fully understood and I think
all of that is relevant
because um a a reductive and exclusive
focus on tension um just as like the
driving mechanism of hypertrophy I think
followed from a very influential paper
um that was misinterpret preted I think
largely because people just didn't
understand the terminology being used um
but that paper the title was stimuli and
sensors that initiate skeletal muscle
hypertrophy following resistance
training by Wacker H and colleagues from
2019 probably butchering the name but
apologies if I did um and so like that
was the paper that I think um really
gave rise to or or at least like gave a
lot of popularity to the idea that it's
just all about tension because
previously the the paper that a lot of
people cited was the uh mechanisms of
hypertrophy article by shenfeld that
argued that tension metabolic stress and
muscle damage were all like mechanisms
of hypertrophy and I think the
terminology was pretty loose in that
paper as well like I wouldn't
necessarily refer to any of those things
as mechanisms of hypertrophy but that
was kind of like that kind of laid the
groundwork for a long time time I think
that paper was from like 2010 then in
2019 uh this paper by Wacker ha was
looking again at sensor stimuli and
sensors that initiate skeletal muscle
hypertrophy and through that lens they
found that like ah like there there are
probably some like specific like sensor
proteins that can feel tension and
initiate that hypertrophy signaling
Cascade and we don't really see that for
metabolic stress or muscle damage or
really um like any other sort of like
external stimuli that or external
stimulus that you would generate from a
resistance training session um but like
in effect they were just looking for
like specific proteins or structures or
molecules that could directly sense the
cell the cellular perturbations induced
by resistance training and then initiate
kick off that cellular signaling Cascade
that I described earlier uh that
eventually results in hypertrophy and
like I said they found that the prime
candidates for Those sensors um seem to
probably respond primarily to tension
rather than muscle damage or biological
stress but it is important to note and
make very clear that initiate doesn't
mean fully CS essentially it gets that
whole process rolling but there are
still so many like different steps and
openings where other like factors can
regulate and either suppress or amplify
the signal that is initially generated
by whatever is kicking off that Cascade
so it could be entirely true that
tension is the only exercise related
cellular perturbation that initiates the
cellular signaling Cascade that
ultimately influences hypertrophy
signaling
but that still doesn't get you
particularly close at all to
establishing tension as directly
causitive of hypertrophy uh and it's
even further from from getting you to
the point of being able to say that it
is like the only Factor that's
influencing
hypertrophy um so like just to zoom out
a little bit uh rather than than
speaking about like mechanisms or
causation or whatever I think it's I
think it's useful to think about it in
terms of necessity and sufficiency and
so now we're we're kind of taking a
little stroll down to uh like philosophy
and logic 101 so um you you can when
you're when you're thinking about like
causations or like contributors to some
sort of complex outcome um it's helpful
to ask like what is necessary and what
is sufficient and so if something is
necessary that means means the outcome
of Interest doesn't occur unless a
particular stimulus or a particular
factor or whatever it may be is present
um sufficient means that the outcome of
interest will necessarily occur if a
particular stimulus is present so for
instance
um oh man I shouldn't I shouldn't have
just tried to to uh freehand an example
here um something will come to mind but
for for our purposes here the the Wacker
H paper
um would support the idea that tension
is necessary for hypertrophy but it
doesn't uh it doesn't come particularly
close to establishing it as sufficient
um so okay okay
um an idea of necessary is like to to
drive in your car it is necessary to
have gas in your tank but having gas in
your tank isn't sufficient to drive
because your car might not have wheels
or like the ignition might not work so
you would say that having gas in the
tank is necessary but not sufficient
whereas um shout out
Elon oh yeah or or have a charged
battery you know for for a classical gas
engine um let's see but uh an idea of
sufficiency would be
like
um uh yeah like to to catch a murder
charge you need to kill someone you
killed someone that is sufficient to
catch a murder charge you know like it
it fully satisfies the criteria um not
the best example but whatever it works
so essentially like there as as the
stimulus as the prime stimulus to kick
off this signaling Cascade we we do have
pretty good evidence that tension is
necessary but that doesn't come
particularly close to establishing that
it is sufficient uh or
and and you could have something that is
sufficient that could still be like
Amplified or muted by other things um so
it comes even farther from establishing
that tension is the only Factor here
that
matters um and I think that that should
be like like that sounds pretty abstract
but I think to make it a little more
practical all of that should be pretty
obvious when you just take a second to
think about this so for instance um
nutrition it's clearly important total
energy intake total protein intake they
certainly influence
hypertrophy
um but so like they are also necessary
but not necessarily sufficient so and
how do they influence hypertrophy well
they don't directly influence how much
tension you can generate right uh but
they do influence multiple steps of that
signaling Cascade between the point of
initiation of the signal in Cascade
which is caused by tension and the point
of actually synthesizing new protein
like the uh signals related to total
energy availability affect kind of like
things Downstream of mtor signaling and
so uh you could have the same tension
stimulus But ultimately you get a
smaller signal leading to like mRNA
creation and and actual protein
synthesis if you're in an energy deficit
because even though the stimulus caused
by tension is the same
uh like Downstream things are modulated
to result in a different outcome similar
with protein um like protein itself like
directly interacts with mtor signaling
and it's going to just influence like
substrate availability like you you need
those amino acids present to synthesize
proteins from amino acids right so um
yeah so just just as one example of like
tension being necessary but not
necessarily sufficient because you need
energy you need protein um steroids are
another good example here so they
clearly increase muscle growth but again
not because they directly influence how
much tension you can generate um they
might over time like after they help you
build more muscle and have more
contractile proteins but that's just
kind of circular reasoning like they
help you get bigger because they've
already helped you get bigger right um
but rather like they directly influence
gene expression on their own independent
of tension like um that's how steroid
hormones work they go into the cell they
bind to an androgen receptor and the
Lian receptor complex translocates to
the nucleus affects gene expression um
and they like steroids also influence
multiple other steps of that signaling
Cascade between the point of tension
generating a signal and that signal
ultimately resulting in protein
synthesis
um phenomenon of muscle memory is also a
good example here so like it's pretty
well established that if you build some
muscle and then take some time off
training and lose the muscle you rebuild
it faster than you built it in the first
place um even if you've lost strength
and can't generate as much tension
anymore after the layoff like you're
you're building muscle faster despite to
generating less tension um and
again like it's not a matter of like
that affecting how well you can initiate
the signal that ultimately results in
hypertrophy it's a matter of everything
that happens between the initial the
initiation of the signaling Cascade and
the point of ultimately synthesizing new
protein in that case um there's research
from from Seaborn showing that it
affects epigenetic modifications which
like I mentioned before uh like on once
you have those myogenic regulatory
factors that influence genic expression
that kind of makes it easier or harder
to like get in to like transcribe mRNA
that codes for particular protein so
like you can have a similar signal um
but like if that DNA is more or less
accessible that could affect like how
much protein you ultimately synthesize
similarly it seems like um myonuclei
stick around even if muscle fiber size
goes down so your translational capacity
per unit of fiber volume is higher so
like it's clearly influencing
hypertrophy doesn't have a goddamn thing
to do with the actual like initi the
tension related initiation of that
signaling Cascade um I feel like I'm I'm
beating a dead horse at this point but
like I'm just going to I'm I'm going to
give a couple more examples like just to
like Hammer this point home uh capillary
density so there was um there was a
study by sniders back in the day um
looking at the relationship between
capillary density and hypertrophy in
older adults um where they they
basically just put everyone on the same
training program and then look to see
like hey what's kind of predictive of
outcomes after the fact and they found
the folks that had higher capillary
density um ultimately saw more
hypertrophy than the folks who had lower
capillary density and then more recently
there was an experimental study in
younger adults that I found like
particularly fascinating they used a
within subject unilateral design uh both
legs had a 10 we resistance training
intervention but one of the legs did six
weeks of unilateral cycling beforehand
um so you know like that's that's cardio
that's that's not going to build muscle
and like it it didn't um it's not like
one leg started way bigger than the
other because they did six weeks of
unilateral cycling but basically two
legs on the same person so like you're
equating for sleep and nutrition and
everything else with within subject um
but just one one leg had done six weeks
if unilateral cycling so it came into it
with higher capillary density they found
that that uh also influenced hypertrophy
where like the the leg that had done the
unilateral cycling that came into it
with higher capillary density
experienced more hypertrophy than the
other leg did um so yeah like that seems
to influence hypertrophy again without
affecting fiber tension um because again
like it's it's affecting Downstream
stuff and it's not entirely clear what
that is like it could just be um like
making substrate more available you can
clear waste a little better um it could
be like higher mitochondrial density
maybe rather than capillaries like
affecting redock status uh and like that
affecting like um amplification or
suppression of of multiple steps of
those signaling Cascades like it's hard
to say but again like it it's not
attension stimulus but like that factor
is influencing hypertrophy responses uh
ineds an inflammatory status just as a
as a final example here um ineds once
again don't influence how much tension
you can generate uh if you if you pop an
Advil like it's not like your squats
going to go down 20 kilos if anything it
might even acutely increase how much
tension you can generate um if you have
like Orthopedic issues and like
suppressing feelings of discomfort could
help you push a little harder or just if
you um like perceive the the burn
associated with exercises particularly
noxious um like inets could help you
like maybe push a little harder and
generate more tension uh but then does
it increase your hypertrophy outcomes
well maybe like it's dependent because
uh it seems like inflammatory status
affects again multiple steps of those
Downstream signaling Cascades between
the point that you initiate the the
signaling Cascade with ATT tension
stimulus and between that point and when
you ultimately synthesize proteins and
so if you're like young and healthy and
have like relatively low levels of
Baseline inflammation it seems like
taking high doses of incets uh
blunts um hypertrophy signaling and
ultimately how much muscle you build
whereas there's uh research on older
adults finding that incets may actually
increase hypertrophy so again like you
have another Factor here just probably
General inflammatory status which is
modulated by ineds that is ultimately
affecting how much hypertrophy you
achieve despite having the exact same
stimulus an initiator of that stimulus
uh that being tension
so um ju just before I keep going do do
you guys have anything to add to that I
I'll just quickly summarize like I
think ultim timately what Greg just kind
of went through and I think we share
very similar thoughts is
ultimately the the kind of common the
common narrative around this is that I
think Greg summarized it initially
really well the A to B to C model where
you have the tensile stimulus that is
going to essentially directly reflect
the
upregulation of muscle protein synthesis
and then that mathematical you know
balance of break down in synthesis
reflects the hypertrophy that we observe
ultimately and the way that I basically
just take everything you just said and
maybe simplify it for the listener to
kind of a mental picture is you know we
have the the arrow of of tension that is
ultimately sensed by the the structures
of the of of the muscle fiber but then
there's this big ass box that the arrow
has to go through before it comes out
the other side and is ultimately going
to lead to the protein synthetic
response that we actually observe and
within that box you have holes on the
top and the bottom for all these
different regulational factors that are
going to reflect the stimulus that is
sensed and the ultimate consequent
biochemicals Cascade and signal that is
delivered finally to the synthetic
pathway and like Greg said there are
dozens upon dozens upon dozens
micro regulations that are occurring
along the entire string of that process
that leads to the simple tension of 10
units equals 10 relative units of MPS
probably is a gross
oversimplification and very likely leads
to inaccurate predictions and I think
just just to hammer home one of the
examples that I think I know people will
be able to identify with is that if you
deliver the same tensile stimulus in the
in a dreamer bulk in in scenario a you
know you're goad starting strength type
type situation versus in in situation B
where you're doing a protein modified
fast for the the third month or whatever
something stupid that energy difference
is going to be obviously a regulating
factor of the the the line of the
tension stimulus to the actual MPS that
we observe and then the final um the the
hypertrophy that actually is accured
from that over time so clearly as Greg
just laid out there is multiple inputs
to this process that leads to while
tension may be a very strong or even
potentially sole initiator the actual
process itself that we're concerned with
that leads to the longitudinal outcomes
that we care about is clearly very
multifactorial and influenced by a ton
of different things completely unrelated
the tension so saying that t
is the only thing we should really
concern ourselves with and ultimately
design training to reflect that is
probably short sided and I don't know if
you guys have anything more to add to
that before we keep moving on yeah I
just want to make a quick Point
regarding you know you might listen to
to what Greg and Zach have said and
maybe think about the difference between
between subjects considerations or
between individual considerations and
within participant or within individual
considerations now Zach actually uh L A
pre-print that's that's out now that
kind of talks about the difficulty of
establishing kind of this this these
causal inferences within an within an
individual so I'll start by adding a
layer of caution um but if you want kind
of a an an overview of some of the
nitty-gritty stuff beyond the obvious
things like steroids and uh you know
like whether you're in a dream or bulk
or not uh there's there's another paper
I believe out of out of Auburn as well
kind of similar group of papers to what
we alluded to before it's called
physiological differences between low
versus high skeletal muscle hypertrophic
responses responders to resistance
exercise training current perspectives
and future research directions and
they're very clear that there's a
inconclusive research for a lot of these
and and um I think this paper was like
from 2020 so there's there's additional
information since then but um and and
Greg alluded to most if not all of these
right things like uh satellite cell uh
Dynamics in response to training things
like capillary number pre-training and
and potentially capillary responses to
training um mitochondrial
volume um ribosomal upregulation is also
a big one and the reason I mentioned
that is I think that that goes to show
that you know from A to B to C there's a
lot of
of substeps if you will right and it
would reason to believe and and if you
see these differences in terms of how
these factors might influence between
individual differences between low and
high responders it would reason to
believe that if you can uh modify these
via some sort of training strategy
that's either unique to the individual
or something that doesn't just satisfy
this A to B to C distinct relationship
it would reason to believe that that
would ultimately influence C which is
which is muscle growth right and we do
have some research within individuals um
there's a paper from hammerstrom uh from
2019 the volume one yeah it's a it's a
basically a within subjects volume study
um very very well done study and
basically some folks responded better to
to lower training volumes some responded
better to to higher training volumes and
they were able to kind of pinpoint
ribosomal biogenesis as a potential
modifying Factor there and again I'm I'm
cringing a little bit because there's a
lot that goes into uh exactly how to
make those determinations on the
individual level but these things have
been elucidated to some degree Beyond
like like on an actual cellular level um
Beyond just again those I think those
obvious ones that that will really
resonate with folks like nutritional
status and and and steroid use
yeah I I I think that's a really good
segue as well because I I suspect a lot
of people were listening to what I was
saying it's like well we're we're
talking about training stimuli here like
ultimately we're talking about a very
like tension focused hypertrophy model
and you're talking about nutrition
you're talking about inets like um you
know all of that stuff could influence
hypertrophy but it wouldn't necessarily
mean that tension wasn't like the only
exercise related stimulus that that
mattered here um but I the the point I
was trying to make with that is just
that given how many like non-tension
factors don't initiate that hypertrophy
signaling Cascade but influence the
outcome of it um and like so you have
that and and also just just how many
like cellular perturbations are induced
by resistance exercise
um like given those two facts like I
really h i really struggle to understand
how someone could just boil all of this
down to tension even if they were to
accept that tension was the sole
initiator of hypertrophy signaling just
because like so many other things
influence all other parts of the
multiple hypertrophy signaling Cascades
um and influence or regulate the
cellular environment that the muscle
fiber uh being exposed exposed to
tension is
experiencing um that like the the
analogy Zach gave of the box where you
have the stimulus into the box what's
going on in the Box who knows what's
coming into and out of the box to
influence everything going on in in the
Box a lot of and then out the other
side of the Box comes an outcome that
hopefully being muscle protein synthesis
um ju just given how many other
Regulators there are and given just how
much stuff exercise does to a muscle
fiber it seems to me uh unbelievably
unlikely that other like exercise
related stimuli wouldn't influence uh
like like heavily influence those
signaling Cascades and ultimately the
outcome you're dealing with even if one
were to accept that tension were the
sole initiator of that Cascade um so
like just just for instance um like the
using the two the two uh like
classically discarded mechanisms of
hypertrophy that that everyone shits on
these days uh metabolic stress and
muscle damage um so like I think it's
entirely likely that there isn't any
specific metabolite that directly
initiates hypertrophy signaling like I I
think that that seems like incredibly
plausible but I wouldn't necessarily be
so confident that those met ites
generated wouldn't for instance uh be a
stimulus for increased capillary density
or mitochondrial
biogenesis um or just like affect kind
of like the general bioenergetic status
of the cell which could then like
influence mtor regulation um and and all
of those things that they themselves
like the the uh the change in chemical
State brought on by those metabolites or
the change in like the state of the
muscle be that cap increases in
capillary density mitochondrial
biogenesis uh Etc like those things
could um like pretty significantly
influence the hypertrophy you achieve
even if none of those um metabolites are
directly initiating that process like
like if one were to fully rule out quote
unquote metabolic stress as an initiator
of hypertrophy that still doesn't come
anywhere close to establishing that it
is not still an important modulating
factor that strongly influences how much
hypertrophy you actually achieve um and
similar with muscle damage like kind of
the flip side of
inets you know that's that's going to uh
increase redo signaling that's going to
increase inflammatory status like if you
damage a muscle um and if from like a
separate line of research we have
evidence suggesting that uh if um kind
of local inflammatory state is either
like too inflamed or too non-inflamed
that that could positively or negatively
influence the hypertrophy that one
achieves it doesn't seem unlikely to me
that changes in local inflammatory
status uh brought on by local muscle
damage could have a similar effect so
again like even if there's no like
direct s
of muscle damage that kicks off that
hypertrophy signaling Cascade that that
again still doesn't get you particularly
close to ruling out some sort of damage
related Factor as a contributor to
hypertrophy that one could achieve
um so yeah like I think I think one of
my my biggest issues with this idea that
I like to term tension
reductionism is that it it does I think
to me reveal a stunning level of
unawareness of just how many open
research questions there still are in
this area and like a pretty alarming
degree of incuriosity or at least a
degree of incuriosity that I would
interpret as
alarming so like the the papers you guys
have recommended I would strongly
recommend as well they're they're some
of my favorites um another one that I
that I toss out there um another uh
another Auburn paper um shout out to
Mike Roberts uh is mechanisms of
mechanical overload induced skeletal
muscle hypertrophy current
understandings and future directions um
it is an absolute monster I don't I
think it might still just be pre-printed
I don't know if it's been published yet
um but like the the pre-print version is
like 126 pages and it has almost a
thousand sources I think it has like 991
and honestly uh Dr Roberts if you're
listening to this like generally it's
not good uh good form to just like add
in extra references to like pader
reference list but like if you're that
close to a thousand like just do it you
know um normal notes yeah but uh yeah
it's it's an excellent
paper and um you know a lot of a lot of
the Heavy Hitters in kind of like
mechanisms of hypertrophy research like
the not not not jabronies like us who
are talking about it on the podcast me
being a much larger Jabron than you guys
because you're you're still actively
involved in research but like the folks
who are actually like doing studies and
taking biopsies and and uh you know
innovating new research techniques to
like study and understand this stuff
better um like a pretty good chunk of
those folks were authors on this paper
and like here is is their conclusion and
so uh you you ah Ju Ju Just compare this
to some of the more confident statements
about causes of hypertrophy that you
might encounter on the internet uh okay
so quoting from the paper a central
tenant of this review is that several
mechanisms are required for mechanical
overload induced skeletal muscle
hypertrophy as shown in the summary
table below and much remains to be
learned in these areas as well skeletal
muscle hypertrophy research has rapidly
evolved since the landmark report by
mergo in
1897 pioneering discoveries in the field
have motivated others to adopt
Innovative methodologies and drive the
research boundaries in meaningful ways
given the rapid advancements in
molecular-based research techniques
investigations in upcoming years will
continue to confirm or refute which of
the discussed mechanisms are obligatory
for rather than coinciding with load
induced skeletal muscle hypertrophy more
importantly these efforts will likely
unveil novel mechanisms that continue to
reshape our thinking in this area of
muscle biology so you know I I would
strongly recommend you read the whole
paper so you would know what those like
other mechanisms they refer to are but
um like that's how they wrap it up and
the folks researching this stuff clearly
believe that there are
still way more questions than answers
and uh I think that if
a non-expert in the area feels otherwise
there's uh pretty decent chance that
they're wrong kind
of so yeah
um
yeah oh go ahead yeah I don't want to I
don't want to cut you off but I think
this might
be it it's important to take a step back
and kind of mention that like the the
soft version
uh of effective reps so so just to to
make sure the listeners on the same page
that reps closer to failure are in
isolation probably a little bit more
hypertrophic than reps further from
failure um we aren't saying that that is
is untrue and and and in fact the the
regressions would uh would support that
but I think Greg kind of where where
you're coming from is that is
a not not completely obvious but at
least sort of obvious state
um yeah
so but the I think where we're taking
issue or where we would at least have a
different perspective is is twofold the
first is that there is a clear
distinction between a repetition that is
is fully or even partly effective um in
terms of that kind of being in an on or
off switch and then secondly as as Greg
you kind of termed this this tension
reductionism kind of viewpoint in terms
of we are optimizing izing for this
input right if you optimize for the
input as opposed to to the output you
can be led astray right and we we've
we've seen this kind of historically
right in terms of optimizing for things
like maximizing EMG values maximizing
for acute muscle protein synthesis
maximizing for other mechanisms that we
kind of assumed drove the hypertrophy
stimulus things maximizing for time
under tension do doing some 30 second
reps growth hormone hell yeah ex
and the the mechanistic stuff I think is
is the most interesting when you can uh
kind of overlay it with longitudinal
outcomes and that's why I like a lot of
the stuff that that Auburn does as we've
mentioned a few times because they they
will try to draw some of those those
relationships right the the paper from
hammerstrom also looks to draw some of
those relationships and then okay once
you see kind of this this pattern in the
research using using the the Met
regression here right we can look at
solely mechanistic papers with without
actual applied outcomes and back
calculate or or generate hypothesis
regarding uh a a mental model that could
apply to some degree but we've been off
before and I don't think there has been
a a dramatic shift in terms of our
understanding of muscle physiology to
assume that we have all the answers now
um but I do think uh not to uh to toot
our own horn too much I do think this
paper is an important step in terms of
understanding one of the
potential training variables that is
going to have a relatively
reliable uh relationship with with the
actual applied outcome of interest of of
increasing muscle size um what
other things from a from a training
perspective and and when I say training
perspective this could also be like a
potential mechanism that could be
applied through training right or or um
a a concept that could be applied
through training do do you guys think
might be a play um we we've kind of
again established that yeah if if you
have
higher uh per fiber tension or or per
fiber Force it's probably going to be a
good thing for hypertrophy but as we
we've said we're skeptical of that being
the the only thing so what other things
would you guys throw into the mix that
would at least to some degree uh kind of
align with the the applied outcomes we
have not not to take us too far off um
off course here but I'm curious to get
Greg curious to get your feedback on
this idea because this is something I've
had ring around in my head for a while
you mentioned you mentioned the muscle
damage thing um
and I don't I don't tend to completely
disagree with the way that's usually
discussed but I have a really weird
feeling in my my stomach when I pretty
much entirely I think there's one study
that people refer to to basically
entirely refute the possibility that
muscle damage is even remotely um at
play with hypertrophy and to be clear
the Damas study that people refer to is
a really really good study um and I
think it does a really good job at maybe
um you know talking about the the
regulation or the initiation process of
muscle damage and things like that
but I've I've always wondered that that
potentially muscle damage is kind of
this um this variable that kind of goes
in waves so initially you know prior to
the repeated bout effect kind of
occurring um to a large extent muscle
damage is going to be high to any um you
know given bout of of resistance
training right and the way that the
narrative is kind of painted in response
to this Damas article is that the
upregulations and muscle protein
synthesis are going to be initially
dedicated towards repairing that muscle
damage and then once that has subsided
the remaining muscle protein synthesis
is going to lead to positive protein
accretion to me that just says that in
that initial bout that's kind of the
time course that happens but I don't see
how like later down the line that that
process couldn't be upregulated again if
you reintroduce aout of muscle damage
and so I just think about you know the
kind of the quote unquote
resensitization effect or or different
things that people kind of have noticed
in practice and kind of the sprinkling
in the research the muscle memory effect
that you've noticed uh that you've
mentioned already like I don't know I
I'm personally not totally comfortable
completely writing off muscle damage as
like one thing that I think out of the
candidate original mechanisms I think
people tend to throw that one out first
and then the um the metabolic stress has
a little bit more of people that are
remaining uh to hold on to that but I
don't know to get your guys's initial
thoughts on that and tell me if I'm
wrong if if the the case in terms of the
primary argument with that goes but to
me I've always thought of it as like
yeah like you're not going to optimize a
program for muscle damage but at least
in theory to me like it could start this
kind of positive wave initially and then
once you've adapted to a stimulus such
that you can basically not increase
muscle damage at all maybe that's where
some of these kind of resensitization
effects at least partially play a role
but I'm I could be off base what do you
guys think damn are people citing Damas
as the main the main evidence against
that these days I think uh I think flann
from 2011 is much stronger okay
um it's uh ah whatever it doesn't matter
but um ah I it it irks me when there's a
strong Citation for something and people
opt for the weak one um but yeah like I
I think that
um I think that that it's probably
relatively context dependent um and I
suspect that that if damage does play a
role um it is probably a kind of like uh
hormesis type relationship where like if
like too little might be bad too much
might be bad and in the case of
untrained lifters they're experiencing
way way more muscle damage than trained
lifters would in the course of normal
training
um and so yeah like I I think it's I
think it's entirely likely that the like
extremely extremely significant muscle
damage that people um experienced during
their first session or two I think it's
entirely likely that that is
nonproductive or potentially even
counterproductive for hypertrophy but
that doesn't come anywhere particularly
close to ruling out um kind of like some
l degree of muscle damage and kind of
the the in the subsequent
inflammatory uh Cascade resulting from
it as potentially being productive um
but yeah like I'm I'm I'm open to it but
I'm also not like super confident in it
uh Ju Just to get a little nutty like I
do
think I'm I'm still like a big I'm a big
metabolic stress
truther um and I I think that that
probably 10 hats on folks here we go
ah I I think I think that relates to
um I think that relates to just like
training volume as well because like
ultimately um like you're you you are
generating less tension each set um and
so like if there were kind of like a
threshold of tension that needed to be
achieved um if it were at all
challenging to reach that threshold in
the first set it would be like
increasingly challenging to reach it in
subsequent sets
um but yeah like I I I think that I
honestly think that there is something
to
um
uh something related to metabolic stress
um and I I think that there's an
interplay with volume there um and and a
lot of that stems from something that
like keeps me up at night which is like
why do muscles stop growing in the first
place because like that that is like an
insane thing that we don't have an
answer to that question yet because and
it's it's also like another example of
kind of the breakdown between acute and
chronic findings because when you just
look at like muscle protein synthesis
and muscle protein breakdown rates in
trained lifters um it doesn't look like
people are in like a super net catabolic
state that they have to like train
really really hard just to like keep
themselves from atropine and when they
do a resistance training workout and
they measure um muscle protein synthesis
you don't see as large or as sustained
of a muscle protein synthetic response
as you do in untrained lifters but you
still see like a pretty robust elevation
in muscle protein synthesis that lasts
for at least like 12 to 24 hours and so
you look at at that kind of like acute
cellular data and it would suggest that
like you should still be able to keep
growing like pretty well basically
forever um but that's not what you see
and I think that it's a a
fascinating uh thing to think about why
so here here's kind of my my nutty idea
I think a lot of it has to do with just
basic bioenergetics and and this is this
is why I think volume is important and
why I'm like a metabolic stress truther
um so ultimately uh people don't think
about the spatial relationship of stuff
with within a muscle fiber but I think
they should because I think it's very
interesting and I think it's very
instructive most of the stuff in a
muscle fiber is near the sarala like
it's near the uh the the the cell
membrane of the muscle fiber um as you
get further and further into the fiber
um you know you'll still come across
like some some granules of glycogen and
you'll still come across um plenty of uh
plenty of actual like contractile
proteins but the mitochondria and the
ribosomes and like I mean the the nuclei
are just like just just right there sub
subar liol um like most most of these
stuff except for contractile proteins is
just crowded around the the borders of
the fiber um because that's where like
most of the stuff is going to happen and
that's
probably a a primary place where like 10
tion is sensed in the first place um
like one one of the main candidates for
aention sensor is some sort of like
costomer Associated protein um like uh A
protein that that helps kind of like
hook the muscle fiber onto the
connective tissue Matrix surrounding it
um and so yeah that's also where like
gas exchange is taking place that's
where you're getting rid of waste
products you're getting a new energetic
substrate getting a new amino acids um
and I mean like all ultimately like if
if uh you're going to like build a new
protein like that starts by transcribing
mRNA like from the nucleus which is just
like right there just like just right
sub Circle liml and so like everything
is crowded around the outside of a cell
and I think a lot of that has to do with
like bioenergetic regulation because one
of the things you see in like all cell
types like this is is this is like only
a Sith speaks in absolutes but like I'm
going to here um like surface area to
volume ratios uh like constraining cell
growth is like a universal fact of
biology like you you see it literally
everywhere um because like
essentially the the stuff the stuff
inside a cell is is what is doing stuff
like what is expending energy what needs
resources um but like in the case of a
ukar cell where you where you get rid of
waste products and where you get new
stuff um whether that be oxygen or
carbohydrate or amino acids or signaling
molecules or whatever um is from the
surface area of the cell like it's it's
diffusing in from
capillaries um and so like I think that
there is I I think that there are just
like basic bioenergetic constraints that
um like limit cell growth and so like
this is this is like maybe like kind of
a nihilistic perspective but I I sort of
think that for like a given level of
like local aerobic capacity uh when
you're talking about what training
variables matter I think you're mostly
just talking about how quickly you're
going to bump up against the limit of
how large your muscle cells can get uh
at a given like level of of bioenergetic
capacity and then I think that to
continue growing like for a muscle cell
to continue growing
um it is going to come down a lot to
kind of like local aerobic and anerobic
conditioning because like that's going
to increase the ceiling um on just like
how much bioenergetic flux a muscle cell
can comfortably handle um and kind of
like you know kind of give itself
permission to grow more it's like okay
we're this big and we're we're not going
to grow anymore because like when this
person exercises hard we we are getting
like kind of close to a bioenergetic
crisis and like that's not good we don't
want to do that we'll have to do
apoptosis no like we're we're not doing
that we're not growing anymore and
then kind of like local uh local
conditioning improves and it's like oh
hey when this person exercises hard now
like it's still kind of uncomfortable
but it's not threatening a bioenergetic
crisis so now let's kind of like take
our foot off the break a little bit and
let this muscle grow a little bit larger
um I don't know I I think I think that's
kind of what's Happening um and like in
instances where you use some sort of
like perturbation to let muscle fibers
grow larger than they otherwise would um
they do tend to not seem to be doing
particularly well so like in in like
myostatin mutant mice that wind up with
like super super big muscle fibers um
they're like pretty weak per unit of
cross-sectional area um and like
essentially the mice look really
impressive but they're not great
athletes because the muscles have grown
larger than they can be useful and so
there's kind of that that tradeoff with
them um
there's some evidence that like steroids
might be similar where kind of like the
the uh Force production per unit of
cross-sectional area might be a little
bit lower um there might be some like
increases in local inflammation perhaps
due to redo signaling perhaps due to the
cells getting too large to do as much
aerobic metabolism as they would like to
do and just kind of like again some some
just kind of like bioenergetic
breakdowns um so yeah I don't know I I
do I do think that that's quite
important I I think that if you're not
particularly close
to your limits of
hypertrophy I think that it's
essentially irrelevant and yeah yeah
just expose the fibers to some tension
they'll grow just fine whatever um and I
think to keep growing past a certain
point and I I think this is why like
volume and not just having attention
stimulus because because like that's
another thing with proximity to failure
that that should be discussed um like
you could look at it through the lens of
you go closer to failure and that's
increasing per fiber tension and like
that is why you see increased growth but
all else being equal I mean if you do a
set of 10 uh with a 10 rep max load you
are also doing two more reps than you
would if you would have done a set of
seven and so that is going to increase
kind of the local metabolic stress it's
probably going to increase muscle damage
a little bit as well kind of like it
it's it's
challenging
to even in that context to say that if
you're seeing more growth that tension
is the driver because like every other
purported mechanism of of hypertrophy
would also be higher going closer to
failure rather than stopping further
from failure um yeah like I I think that
that's maybe one of the things
contributing to increased growth when
training closer to failure I think
that's one of probably one of the things
contributing to increased growth um with
with high training volumes as well one
of the things that that is I think like
kind of striking I guess is that
um one of the studies oh man I'm
blanking on the author it was a
Brazilian study but in in the in the
volume literature
um
the I think the strongest result in
favor of uh like higher training volumes
even with like with short bre intervals
and all of that um leading to more
growth is like Far and Away the longest
study on on training volume at least in
like healthy subjects that's been done
it was like a six-month paper and Rody
ell or no do what Rod Elli is that the
one you're talking about yeah yeah yeah
um yeah like you're you tend to see ah
like maybe maybe small often
non-significant differences in
hypertrophy with higher training volumes
like in most of the research in the area
like in that one study short rest
intervals super high training volumes
high volume seemed to be very good um
and so you know it it could just be that
like you you need kind of a longer run
time in a study for folks to maybe have
like constraints on hypertrophy that
higher levels of volume and more
metabolic stress would help kind of
alleviate and and let them continue
growing like
I don't know I I don't want to overe
extrapolate from one study but just kind
of like noodling a little bit that's
that's kind of my my view of hypertrophy
I think I think that ultimately the the
interesting question isn't necessarily
what will help you grow faster because
like if if you're a Natty and you're and
you're you're doing well for yourself
and you're training right and all of
that like shit's going to get pretty
like you're you're going to get to
pretty tough sledding after probably
five or six years um and if you're not
training that well or that smart yeah
maybe it's going to take you a decade
but like you I think you kind of get to
the same place regardless sure and so
the the question turns to like well how
how do we keep things going after that
and I I really do I really do think like
metabolic factors and like local
bioenergetic factors um at least for me
are kind of like the prime candidate uh
for things serving as that constraint on
further growth and I I would I would
like to see more more research on that
so I mean I think the the Nugget there
from from like in reference to the
primary conversation is we just outline
two pretty plausible additional
components to this equation that can
very you know plausibly play a role um
in addition to the kind of the primary
tension initiating kind of rabbit hole
we discussed there so I think
yeah in addition to the the conclusion
you read from the Roberts paper those
are two you know primarily drawing on
the longitudinal evidence there to very
plausible additional cases that could
modify hypertrophy from the longitudinal
literature that you know are outside of
the the tens the tension you know
primary Rabbit Hole there um and and
just underlines how how much we have to
go in terms of understanding this and
being able to predict outcomes at a you
know a perfect level which I think
sometimes it's communicated um like we
can do that but Josh I don't know if
anything to add yeah we have uh an
analysis planned to basically be able to
compare the dose response relationship
between training volume and and high
perch
outcomes with with different rest
periods so like say less than 90 second
rest or less than two minute rest or
greater than that um and I if if I'm
picking up what you're putting down Greg
basically your point is that with
shorter rest periods if so let me take a
step back if tension is is the only
thing that matters um with shorter rest
periods you would expect to see less of
a dose response relationship is that
accurate or a a less convincing dose
response
relationship um but but between what two
factors between volume and hypertrophy
or what
yeah um
yeah volume and hypertrophy given the
the rest interval conditions is what
you're talking about right so because
because you would get less and less
uh yeah you would get Le um metabolic
stress might become the kind of the
limiter if you will um for those later
sets later in the session and and I'm
thinking about this uh right now as as
as we speak so I might be missing
something yeah potentially I mean I
I I could see I could see in that
context the productive stimulus changing
over the course of a workout where um
you know
maybe ah like this this is this is like
hopelessly reductive but whatever maybe
with like long rest intervals you you
can do like five productive sets like
you're recovering well and tension's
high enough like whatever with shorter
rest intervals maybe only like the first
three are productive because you're
accumulating fatigue faster you can't
generate as much tension blah blah blah
whatever but then if you're doing like
12 of those sets ah like maybe only the
first three were kind of like directly
relevant for attention stimulus but then
like once you've done enough of them
it's now kind of like transitioned into
being an aerobic stimulus that could
stimulate further like mitochondria
uh biogenesis greater capillary density
um you know Etc and
so yeah like I I I I wonder if like the
the what what is constituting the
productive stimulus there would would
even be the same like from the start of
the workout to the end of it yeah it's
It's Tricky and this is why it's so
difficult to uh make these logical
conclusions using applied research is
because
just just kind of thinking about it
right now I think the the variables that
would drive metabolic stress would be
proximity to failure which also
contributes to per fiber per fiber
mechanical tension uh training volume as
you noted Greg which also would kind of
have an additive effect in terms of
tension and then I also think lower
loads would contribute to higher
metabolic stress um but per fiber
mechanical tension is speculated to be
kind of similar near the end of a set no
matter what load is used so the things
that are going to contribute to
metabolic stress are also going to kind
of contribute to uh profiber mechanical
tension in an applied setting there are
some
Nifty research designs in an applied
sense to get some insights outside of
that and there was a a
pre-printed metaanalysis comparing Blood
Flow Restriction Training to traditional
training and they basically broke it
into uh like two separate analys anes so
a common protocol in the research with
bfr is using the same load you go 30
reps rest like 30 to 60 seconds 15 reps
rest 30 to 60 seconds 15 reps again 30
to 60 seconds 15 reps again so 30 15 15
15 so they did analysis comparing
traditional training to that 30 15 15 15
sort of approach and then they also did
a separate analysis comparing
traditional training to bfr training
with that that went to failure right and
basically what you see is that um in
each of those separate analyses right
there was no difference between the the
training approaches right so in other
words bfr training seems to be similar
in Effectiveness to traditional
training regardless of clear control of
of proximity to failure now we've seen
proximity to failure not really play out
in kind of a traditional meta analysis
before so I don't want to over index on
that but it does make me wonder if with
bfr training we we we think we know that
uh sort of the acceleration of fatigue
if you will can contribute to per fiber
mechanical tension but given that kind
of small hint there that
perhaps that's not the only thing going
on with something like Blood Flow
Restriction I've also I'm also aware of
at least one study um where simply using
bfr cuff uh bfr Cuffs in the absence of
of any contractions if if if I'm
recalling correctly was able to at least
attenuate atrophy compared to the
alternative of of you know uh no bfr at
all and no
contractions um which which makes me
wonder if there is kind of this uh this
this independent role um but again it's
really hard to separate in these applied
outcome studies and then the last thing
to layer on there is like okay even if
it is is that additive right or would
that just be redundant in terms of
ultimately you know to kind of use our
our oversimplified model is that
ultimately uh additive or redundant in
terms of driving up B and driving up C
in terms of that that process of muscle
growth the one the one additional area
that honestly
was I would say I
was maybe 8020 in the camp of kind of
the
tension is from the practical
perspective is ultimately one of the
only things that matter before your
initial um effective reps article but
then the couple studies that you pulled
out that at least brought me back to
reality and kind of opened my mind to be
pretty agnostic on it was the the few
studies that Ed that additional set of
like 20% of one orm oh yeah those are
really really interesting um and so just
to kind of to line it up for the the
reader on kind of how that line of
reasoning works is that so this isn't
super well researched in terms of the
bottom cut off of kind of the loading
spectrum that we can expect hypertrophy
from but there's one decent study that
finds that 20% of 1rm even when taken to
what I'm going to call task failure is
insufficient to produce you know
meaningful
hypertrophy and so at the end of Greg's
effective reps article he cites a few of
these studies that basically perform the
exact same training program but they add
in these you know metabolic stress
sets um that take approximately 20% of
one RM and and take like one set to
failure um I think in one study it might
be a little bit more than one set um so
obvious limitation they're not set
equated in that instance but based on
that other research we wouldn't expect
that to elicit an independent tensile
effect because you know on its own it
doesn't seem to produce hyper
necessarily
um but when in combination that seems to
actually improve hypertrophy compared to
the condition of only doing you know
time traditional type training um the
only other caveat there is that I
believe in at least one of the ones that
you cited that they performed the the
kind of the fatigue set before um all of
the training that and I believe the way
that the training was prescribed it
didn't control proximity to failure so
conceivably you know one really
fatiguing set could kind of influence
the proximity of failure of all the
other training that comes after it but
at least one of them it was after and so
yeah Pho study yeah one of them one of
them the fatigue set was was after and
that to me is a pretty interesting case
um for kind of the the additive effects
of of the kind of the metabolic stress
kind of oriented um type thinking so I I
don't know if you have any additional
commentary on that but I always thought
that was at least like I said kind of
brought me back to reality to remain
agnostic on the topic to say like all
right this isn't perfectly predicted by
kind of the way that we think about
things so I'm going to you know not be
as confident about this
ultimately yeah that that's uh that that
that's a pair of studies that have been
rattling around in my head a little bit
um the other ones that that come to mind
are the the research out of Japan the
tricep study I think by AA saara would
be the most wellknown but
um uh looking at like the relationship
between like
oxyhemoglobin desaturation and
hypertrophy with uh the the tricep study
was like full range of motion versus
kind of like so so 120 degrees of elbow
flexion to Zer degrees of elbow flexion
versus uh 90 to 45 degrees of elbow
flexion so like if you're if you're a
full range of motion guy you should
think full range of motion would do
better if you're a long muscle links guy
guy you would think that full range of
motion would do better because you're
you're going all the way down to 120
degrees of flexion but they saw more
triceps growth with just the 90 to
45 um and they found a uh not like super
strong but decent relationship between
observed hypertrophy and uh observed
like hemoglobin desaturation uh during
training so as I guess kind of like a
proxy for metabolic stress or whatever
um so yeah like that's that's always
been in the back of my
mind I don't know I mean ultimately
ultimately my my takeaway is that like I
don't have any firm answers and I think
that like if some of these things
contribute it's just kind of a question
of like how much and for whom and like
in what contexts like like for
instance I I so uh like like let's you
let's use metabolic stress as an example
like there there are two potential ways
maybe that it could contribute to
hypertrophy it could be that it is
causing um adapt like it is also
longitudinally causing other adaptations
that they themselves influence the
hypertrophy response so like in this
model the metabolic stress you
experience during training has no effect
on the actual like muscle protein
synthetic response you get from training
but um the metabolic stress that you
generate causes an increase in
mitochondrial density an increase in
capillary density longitudinally and as
you like as you acre those longitudinal
adaptations it is those adaptations that
then might make uh like might help kind
of like amplify and help you get better
results from a similar tension stimulus
down the road another potential uh
option is that it could be kind of
influencing um you know inter
intermediate steps of the hypertrophy
signaling Cascade like you kick off the
Cascade with a tension stimulus and then
in kind of like the the preor post imor
stage of that signaling Cascade
something related to metabolic stress I
don't know maybe just like helps
increase the efficiency of creating
splice variants of igf-1 so you get more
mechano growth factor uh going on uh
than you would have if you had like less
metabolic stress and that uh even with
the same tension stimulus leads to like
greater um Gene transcription and and
more muscle protein acral like
those those would have like very
different um like broad applications um
because like for instance if you were
training a um an endurance athlete and
they wanted to do some resistance
training like put put some muscle on
like help um help like reduce injury
risk or whatever if it's the first one
that like you know the metabolic
stimulus increases mitochondrial density
and capillary density and that is how it
has a like permissive role for
increasing hypertrophy you wouldn't need
to think about that at all for the
endurance athlete you would just say
like no we're just doing tension
stimulus for you because you already
have great mitochondrial density and
capillary density if it were the latter
then you'd say oh like this would
probably still be productive for you you
know um like you you generate the
tension and then via this metabolic
stress we create the cellular
environment that would help amplify the
signal ini initiated by that tension
stimulus um and yeah like either of
those could be true both of them could
be uh only one or the other
could be true who knows like uh theme of
this episode lot of open
questions uh
and you know it it could also just be
that like some things
require kind of like specific tailored
training approaches and some don't um or
or there might just be like more
efficient ways to train so like the the
example of a lower load set um before
after your heavy training let's just say
like I I don't know if this is true but
like let's just assume that the benefits
of training volume
are entirely due to the fact that they
increase the metabolic stress you
experience during a training session
like I I don't think that's true but
like let's just assume
that if that were the case then like ah
maybe you generate enough tension dur
during your first like two or three sets
and then you have two options you could
either do five more sets of 10 to ramp
your volume enough up enough to like
increase metabolic stress enough to to
positively influence those Downstream
signaling Cascade things or you could
just do like one set of 20% of one RM to
failure um and and that would cause like
a similar metabolic stimulus and
therefore lead to the same outcomes you
know um then then that gives you options
like if someone would rather go heavy
it's like ah cool like we'll just do
more sets someone is kind of a masochist
and wants to do a set of 40 and hate
their life cool like we'll just
do the one hard Set uh if someone is
interested in like time efficiency it's
like oh well we're definitely just going
to do the the one lower load set you
know like it it would it would give
options and kind of like help help you
better understand if if things things
you're doing could be accomplished more
efficiently or um you know if things
overlap enough that they become
redundant
yeah yeah and and and perhaps the worst
part of perspective is it might depend
on unique physiological factors perhaps
related to previous training history or
other things that aren't even on my
radar I think to the the rest period
research um there are at least a couple
studies that lean in favor of of shorter
rests um but if I if I'm recalling
correctly right now uh they were both in
kind of unique populations so one of
them was in uh untrained older adults
and then one of them I think it was was
one of the studies uh was in
like 18yearold or something like that
which I don't think had like uh distinct
resistance training history perhaps and
and maybe just a result of their their
age as well didn't have some of
those uh those adaptations that could be
uh those those local metabolic
adaptations just to kind of use broad
brushs here um so so maybe it becomes
completely irrelevant when you establish
a baseline of that and and it's uh no
longer productive or maybe it's
something that has kind of a a
short-term effect some of the bfr
studies that kind of have like eye
popping hypertrophy from uh you know
dropping in a couple weeks of of low
load Blood Flow Restriction Training
kind of come to mind there as well um so
there's there's additional questions
once you get to the point of or if you
get to the point of whether this is
something that has any Merit at all
right of of kind of combining these
different mechanisms uh is like okay now
for who right and when and and and that
would probably be a whole another step
in and of itself um let alone the
complexities of of actual actually
establishing some of the the predictors
we might want um in terms of determining
who who it would be useful for um yeah
yeah one of the um one one of the
studies published in recent years that
that I have personally really liked was
um
oh uh published last year uh carero was
the author um different load intensity
transition schemes to avoid plateau and
no response and lean body mass gain in
postmenopausal women um I I think it's I
think this paper was was a good example
of that because like the subjects in
this study one they kind of served as
their own control although not
temporally um like it wasn't a within
subject unilateral design but it it was
a crossover paper so um basically they
did one uh one like one approach to
training for three months and then
switched over and did another one and uh
another group of people did the same two
approaches to training but in the
opposite order order and it was kind of
like a classic moderate load versus low
load study so training with uh like 8 to
12 RM loads versus 27 to 31 don't know
why they went for 27 to 31 instead of 25
to 30 but whatever I didn't design the
study I don't make the rules um and yeah
like the the kind of highlevel like
group level results were in keeping with
what one would expect from moderate load
versus low load studies like uh on
average the uh the hypertrophy was
similar following both approaches to
training um well I shouldn't say
hypertrophy gains in lower body lean
soft tissue Mass which whatever
hopefully that's close enough um but
then like they also reported individual
data which um like I I I understand you
know issues of like measurement accuracy
and regression to the mean and all of
that like you can't NE necessarily
assume that observe variation is actual
variation like blah blah blah I get it
but also I mean some of the some of the
intra individual differences observed in
responses like in response to these two
approaches to training were were large
enough in magnitude that I like
absolutely think that at least for some
of the subjects that they were like
quite real sure so like just for one
example um like one of the subjects had
a 5% reduction in lean soft tissue Mass
following moderate load training and a
10% increase with low load training like
another one uh kind of on the opposite
had a 133% increase following moderate
low training and only a 3% increase with
low load training like like big enough
differences in responses that for sure I
think it's pretty suggestive of like in
actual like legitimate intra individual
difference in responses to those
different training stimuli which if you
you looked at it through an effective
repins you'd say oh no like they're
training to failure like both um both uh
intensities would have had the same
number of effective reps per Set uh
everyone should have experienced the
same hypertrophy with both moderate and
low load training um and like you do see
that on a group level but if that was
your takeaway you're like oh like it it
really doesn't matter either in general
or for you specifically like that would
be pretty bad advice to a non-trivial
number of those subjects
um so yeah like I I think I I think that
there there are like plenty of
suggestions that they're like the
optimal approach to training can
probably vary quite a bit personto
person um like another another thing
that you guys have alluded to um several
times is like it might even vary within
an individual over time like I I'm like
kind of I'm also like kind of a novelty
truther um uh oh here we go joshh is
perked up here we go are are you are you
Pro or anti novelty hell yeah hell yeah
my man do we not do we not just grow for
four weeks like every every two years no
yes dude like the
the like I I I have like this this
little cycle that I run from time to
time that um like it's like the dumbest
thing like I I start with my my 10 rep
max squat and uh just like go go up and
wait every week um and try not to lose
reps and
like for six weeks it always just
works like my leg my legs blow
up my squat goes up it's great and then
it just stops working and like if I
immediately go back to my 10 rep max and
start building up again just doesn't
work like it never works twice but it
always works once um and it's and it's
not just because like I'm starting out
bad in that rep range like even if I'm
like pretty conditioned going into it uh
if if i' if I'm doing that following
like a lower rep training block like it
always works um and then it just like
stops working but then if I do go back
to to lower rep training even if um you
know even if like due to lack of
specific or like even even if my
performance hasn't gone down like lower
rep training does become just like more
effective again uh after after doing
that block like yeah I I think there's
something there honestly that's kind of
the grounds that I've always you know I
call it muscle damage to me it's mostly
just like that's a proxy of novelty
because you know the more custom you get
to a stimulus typically the less muscle
damage you get um but that's that's kind
of always the way that I've thought
about it is
like the there seems to be a shelf life
for a given organization of training
variables MH such that once you get
adapted enough to it that you know it
kind of seems like it's run its course
and then you know people that you know
run their head into the wall with the
same organization of training variables
for a really long time um and they don't
make progress for like you said Josh for
like two years and then they you know
try a substantial shift in in in
something then maybe that those
productive mechanisms to certain things
that they've accustomed themselves to
you know you come back to hitting some
15s on front Squat and now your
adductors are screaming at you um
certain things like that like that's
always kind of been my experience too is
like you deviate from what you've held
on to really tightly and then in the
long run that kind of seems to pay off
and and that's that's always what I've
kind of like spit B on the back of my
head with the uh the muscle damage thing
that's like it's starting another kind
of round of
productive um you know because MPS for
example is highest when you're getting
contributions from both the recovery of
damage but also the accretion of
theoretically new tissue right so maybe
that's a positive thing initially until
you kind of let that damage slips side
you have like a positive adaptation
window for a while and then it goes away
again because now you're perfectly
adapted that's kind of you know I know
something I've thrown around on my head
but I'm with you guys I'm also a novelty
enjoyer I I've always wondered if
um if if kind of like
so period is a
is one of those things
like it's like so popular in the wild
but it's not that strongly supported in
the research um particularly for
hypertrophy and honestly I kind of think
for strength too I think that there are
some methodological issues like the
periodized groups almost without fail
end up training with higher loads before
testing it's like yeah well did
periodization do it or did this group
train with 90% in the three weeks before
testing and the other group Train was 70
H who knows anyway but like yeah the the
research isn't that compelling
especially for hypertrophy but it's like
periodized approaches to training are
still like extremely popular in practice
um and like I do wonder if some of that
is just kind of like Market forces where
if you're a coach you can't just tell
people ah try to add five pounds if you
can forever because eventually they'll
be like what what am I paying you for um
but I do I do think that it might also
like partially be practical where um you
know maybe maybe it's something that you
wouldn't necessarily observe in a
12-week training study but if someone
were to just use the exact same approach
to training for two years they've fully
habituated to it they're getting nothing
out of it anymore but if they're just
always doing like eight-week hypertrophy
block eight week strength block 8we
hypertrophy block eight we strength
block they never get adapted enough to
either one that it stops being
productive and so you know if you could
run that theoretical two-year training
study um you you might see something
that you wouldn't necessarily observe in
12 weeks like I I think that I'm I'm
extremely open to that possibility even
even from a logistical perspective I was
going to say like you know we're running
a training study right now which is
probably the longest one that we've ever
done um sorry guys easily um yeah sorry
Greg Greg before you were uh you you
kind of waved your hand at some the
things required to establish
interindividual variation and we're
three4 of the way done with just a
monster study that's it's it's Z's
dissertation I don't want to speak for
you but uh I felt your pain Zach because
it's it's
effectively doubles the work of a normal
normal doubles the work of a normal
study all I was gonna say with that yeah
it's been a pain but um uh what I was
going to say with that is like having
these participants
go for so long um with a similar
training protocol like I could also see
from a wild perspective like the
benefits of periodization very much
could be logistically driven just from
the sense that performing the exact same
program for you know a year like you're
not you're not enjoying that training
with the same Vigor in the second six
months of that right like it just just
logistically doesn't even work so it
could be a combination of both the
physiology because I think 12we training
study Recreation only trained
participants their adaptive window to a
given stimulus particularly when the
stimulus they're on in the training stud
is probably the most productively
they've trained for a lot of these
individuals Progressive overload people
loading the weights for them uh you know
whole whole gamut of you know this is
you got grad students yelling at them oh
yeah the whole gamut of like this is a
luxury training environment for all
intents and purposes that adaptive
window to that stimulus is probably
going to always surpass the duration of
a training study um so the Practical
points of those types of interventions
whether it be novelty whether it be
periodization things like that once
you're People Like Us that have trained
for you know five to 10 years maybe that
stuff starts to become a little bit more
re relevant because you're your your
training cycle that you just talked
about you know you get six weeks out of
it but then it hits that hard cut off
for somebody who's just taken that for
the first time that's probably going to
last them you know probably multiple
months um so that that could also be
kind of a a constraint um operating from
that end to we we've we've gotten pretty
far off of uh proximity faure and
effective reps but um one of the uh one
of one of like the papers that I
remember when it was published um a lot
of people had snarky things to say about
it was uh it was like a narrative review
by lencki from maybe like 2018
2019 um about essentially like how long
muscles grow in response to resistance
training be do what yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah infin infinite Beyond yeah
that's what tag I remember and like the
the basic takeaway is like it it
differed by muscle group but um you know
essentially he looked at studies that
assessed um muscle size at at least
three points in time like at least
pre-study midstudy poststudy instead of
just pre and post um and look to see
kind of like how long you could you
could kind of push out that midstudy to
poststudy window and still see
appreciable gains from mid-study to
poststudy and like for for most muscle
groups he his takeaway was like yeah it
seems like muscle stop growing after
about 12 weeks like why why is everyone
out here training for hypertrophy when
you hit the gym like you're going to
stop growing in three months anyways
which practically like I disagree with
that but also I don't think his
interpretation of of the research was
wrong um and so yeah like I I absolutely
think people can grow for well over
three months maybe even years um but
like when you when you look through his
analysis like he is kind of right that
in training studies that use the same
training intervention for like six
months you don't really see much growth
for the last three um and so yeah like
if that is true and if in the real world
we continue to see people making gains
past three months I feel like that is
like pretty strong incident incidental
evidence for novelty being relatively
important because it does seem like even
even in what you described as a luxury
training environment it does seem like
like 12 weeks is is about all you got um
at least for a lot of folks so yeah I
don't I don't know I I do think I do
think think novelty is important I a
potential or or something that's been
rattling around in in my brain um my the
plan for my dissertation is to be
specifically on on skeletal muscle
resensitization is kind of like is there
a micro novelty effect um with like the
NIS study that came out recently of
course the the average volumes were
different um but also the two groups
that saw greater hypertrophy at least in
terms of effect sizes uh they took a a
volume progression approach so anyway
from kind of looking at that any
research we have that does give some
insight into uh kind of a volume
progression or a volume cycling type of
approach um as including that NIS study
again looking at those again through
with kind of a different lens I'm
becoming more sympathetic to that type
of training approach um because it could
provide this sort of novelty effect on a
shorter time scale um if there is
inherent value to to the novelty um but
that could be completely off Bas but you
know should have some experimental
insights into this I I hate to I hate to
keep going down this rap hole I was
going to try to get us back to effective
reps but gotta keep going with this so I
know you guys are probably aware of
really is turning into the the data
driven strength asper teame episode hey
we can break it up into multiple Parts
it'll be fine um
so to kind of counter what you guys are
saying again I'm on the same side of it
there's probably a window you don't want
to be on the other side at least from an
Effectiveness standpoint because there's
a few of those Studies by deas where
they basically do like a
random uh alteration of the training
session um I think it was like just one
of them off top of my head is like high
load low load Ecentric
overload uh rest
interval something like that and they
kind of cycle through those randomly um
it wasn't worse which I think also kind
of goes against The Narrative of like
you have to stay on the exact same
training regimen to see an Adaptive
response but it also wasn't better um
but they didn't do volume progression to
to your your point Josh so maybe that's
the the in an acute sense that's the
most important variable but that I I
think those are interesting to add to
the fire of this tangent yeah I could
take that Damas study and and you know
make a make an argument from both sides
for sure
uh yeah there's also the de Margo I
believe is how you pronounce it that's
almost certainly not how you pronounce
it but they had a met analysis it was
from like three or four studies they
they effectively did like a met analysis
on the individual subjects um looking at
changes in training volume and uh
resultant resultant growth um kind of
independent of the absolute training
volumes they used during the experiments
and they did see a relationship now
you could interpret their relationship
in many ways with the data they reported
it was it's kind of hard to to make
sense of at least from my perspective
again from what they
reported but man uh if you see a
relationship
there outside of like like like just
thinking about all the variables that
would have gone into what drives an
individual to to grow or not to grow if
you see any relationship there does make
me wonder if if there's something so
anyway I have a lot of thinking to do on
this uh in the next few months before I
uh I propose my dissertation my my
memory of
that of that uh deargo paper and and I
could I could be completely
misremembering it was that the studies
that fed into it didn't have volume
progression in terms of like increases
in sets I I I wasn't it just like volume
load
progression yeah yeah so so what they
did is they had pre-training volumes for
all all of the subjects and then of
course they had the assigned training
volum oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
were able to say like okay if you
increased if you decrease volume you go
in this bucket if you increased by zero
to 50% you go in this bucket if you
increased by more than 50% and you're
talking about set volume to yeah that's
right that's right yeah so there's some
Clues um or or some hints that it's it's
something worth looking at um but unless
you guys have anything to add kind of on
this novel to your set progression front
might be a good time to okay take all uh
take all the caution off the table to
whatever degree you feel comfortable and
uh just get to some of the I guess our
practical takes because at the end of
the day got to train gotta coach people
and you know you have to do that despite
the uncertainty so I guess you guys have
any final thoughts on
the novelty stuff or anything to throw
out there for I was going to take us
down one more mechanistic rabit hole if
we want to but if both you guys are
tapped out I can definitely hold that to
another conversation but um I don't know
what you guys think Josh you're you're
the adult in the room what do you
think I'm I'm I'm not opposed to it but
it's uh we're going on three hours Greg
you want to resp I want to respect your
time do you want another tangent
mechanisms Rabbit Hole or no uh I mean
I've I've got another hour 15 before my
shot I'm glad you didn't say the the
name of the shot because then
uh this would be this YouTube might this
video might not have getting taken down
there we go um all right I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna give you the diet version
maybe we can still get so we're going to
have a hard hard 30 minute cap on this
part of it and then we can get to the
last 30 potentially of uh the Practical
stuff so I guess I guess the one thing
are we not going to talk about uh is
force maximized on the fiber level
that's that's that's what I was going to
bring up okay yeah that's what I was
going to bring up because I I I wasn't
going to make all your notes on this go
tote um
so I I guess I guess the thing I was
going to put forth is ultimately Josh
kind of the way me me and you tried to
put together some of this research and
kind of one of the things it hinges upon
is kind of that that tensile uh force
that individual fibers experienced close
to failure um is kind of one of the
things we've we've speculated maybe
explaining kind of how things work um as
we've already said in this episode
clearly that's not the only factor that
is responsible for the entire Cascade
and I don't think we've ever made claims
associated with that but I do think it
it would it would be something I would
put forth as kind of like a a decent
mental model to kind of explain some of
the longitudinal outcomes that we've
seen um but definitely not the way I
would use like I wouldn't use that as
the primary way to prescribe training
more so taking the longitudinal outcomes
and kind of back calculating okay how
could this kind of make sense
so I guess I guess to kind of explain
the way that I think about it and then
we can get to the point you just talked
about about is force maximize on the
fiber level as we near failure is that
okay in a set to failure with heavy
loads somewhere 80% plus we are near
maximizing if not totally maximizing
motor unit recruitment kind of out the
gate if we're using maximal concentric
intended velocity on every rep as kind
of a given throughout this
example so all the motor units are
recruited all the fibers that they
interv are presumably activated and as
we kind of progress closer to failure
each one of those fibers is kind of
sensing or feeling as you said earlier a
large mass right so the the whole muscle
force is decreasing throughout the set
and then presumably the fibers that are
kind of minimally fatigued at the end of
the set are kind of sensing on a per
fiber level the highest amount of amount
of force because it's a given amount of
torque that's distributed over a fewer
number of fibers that are not like
fatigued a ton basically it's kind of so
that's that's the logic we get to say
that okay initially whole muscle force
is the greatest but it's distributed
across the greatest number of active
fibers thus per fiber tension or per fi
per fiber force is low then as we
progress throughout a set some fibers
fatigue I think that's going to be kind
of the the interesting kind of
discussion associated with this some
fibers fatigue therefore the mass that
we're now Distributing or the torque
requirements is being distributed on a
fewer number of fibers that are that are
producing Force such that the force on
those fibers is increasing um also the
force velocity relationship on the fiber
level is also going to play into that
that's kind of how you get to that
rationale now conversely for a low load
set the idea would be there is we kind
of need fatigue or need to um have some
sort of uh requirement that necessitates
greater motor unit recuitment throughout
that set so we have a smaller absolute
Mass that's being distributed over a
small pool of fibers because it does not
necessitate maximal M of unit
recruitment to lift that mass so
throughout that entire set we basically
have high per fiber mechanical tension
because at any one snapshot in time
there's a smaller pool of fibers that
are basically contributing to the
Loading demands this is kind of sort of
what EMG research has kind of picked up
over the years is that anyone snapshot
for a low load set EMG te tends to be a
little bit lower but if you kind of
summate it or look at the area of the
curve you kind of get a different kind
of line of reasoning and so at the end
of that low load set well and now with
um
with like the the emgd comp techniques
can on the level of a motor unit yep yep
um and so I'm not going to pretend to
play hard ball with that kind of stuff
um so any anyway as you kind of get um
towards the end of the set for low loads
presumably that's when the highest
threshold motor units that are inating
the fibers that we assume grow the most
those ones will be under the highest
amount of uh per fiber tension
Distributing lifting that mass thus
that's kind of how you arrive at the
idea that okay at the end of a set to
failure both with heavy and low loads
the low the high loads that kind of have
high tension um throughout but with low
loads it's really at the end of the set
that the per fiber force is high is kind
of the the the uh the idea from our
perspective now whether or not that is
the only thing to care about in that
equation as we already mentioned as you
go through that process metabolic stress
is also accumulating so that very much
could have an uh an a secondary
influence on this entire Cascade I'm not
going to rehash our entire conversation
that we just had but okay with that kind
of line of reasoning put forth and I
believe that's kind of one of the
underlying premises of the effective
reps model at least in the hard sense
what do you think about that what are
your um challenges to it
Etc yeah I so I think that um I think
that most of that is true
the um the the open
question is not whether the highest
threshold motor units are at their
highest level of tension that they will
achieve during the set at the end of a
set but rather whether the tension
achieved by those highest threshold
motor units is particularly close to the
maximum tension they can generate by the
end of a set um because like essentially
the the effective reps idea is
predicated on the idea that like each
fiber has to achieve a pretty high
tension threshold like near maximal per
fiber tension for it to stimulate a
hypertrophic response so that that's
kind of the the um like like new nuanced
uh discussion
question um and I kind of think that it
probably
depends probably pretty heavily on what
loads you're lifting um like I I think
that it's I think that it's very
plausible that with a relatively heavy
load
um like most fibers and most motor units
will be exposed to something approaching
maximal tension um I I I do wonder how
close to their theoretical maximums they
actually get to just because during
normal Dynamic training you're
constrained by concentric Force
production which is lower than isometric
Force production um and you you will
still experience some degree of like
motor unit cycling or like fatigue
within motor units and so you know for
instance if you have a pool of uh 150
motor units that are being recruited and
the one with the highest recruitment
threshold is still recruited from from
the very jump but it is also the most
glycolytic it fatigues the fastest maybe
like if you're doing a set of eight it's
recruited on set one but it can't
achieve maximal tension because uh
velocity is still relatively high and
then it fatigues throughout the set and
then by the by the point the contraction
velocities are relatively slow and
theoretically the the fibers are
Contracting slow enough that a fiber
could theoretically achieve maximal
tension by that point the highest
threshold motor unit might already be
fatigued enough that it is no longer
capable of generating maximal tension
like I I think that that's um I think
that that's possible but I do I do think
that um most motor units are probably uh
being exposed to quite a bit of tension
from the jump and are being exposed to
quite a bit of tension throughout um so
yeah like I I think that that's probably
quite plausible with heavy training with
lighter training though um I think that
it's probably worth referencing a 2017
paper by poen and
fugon I'm I know I'm butchering that but
I'm doing my best um which was uh so the
title of the paper is a a motor unit
based model of muscle fatigue um and so
this was a model meant to be like
directly applied to isometric exercise
but I think it still like conceptually
applies to Dynamic
exercise um and one of the predictions
of this model so like one thing to note
about it is like the underlying logic of
this model is um kind of like baked in
to the effective reps idea like they're
both predicated on Hinman size principle
or the principle of orderly recruitment
the idea that as Force demands uh are
sustained over time you need to recruit
more motor units the new motor units you
recruit will need to uh ramp up in terms
of the tension they're generating and
their firing rates to make up for other
motor units that are fatiguing
throughout a set like that's that that
is the same logic baked into this
model and it would predict that with
like moderate to low loads the highest
threshold motor units probably don't get
particularly close to their maximal
tension um and the reason for that is
just that like enough other motor units
are fatiguing over time so like for
instance if um and and like this is
another one where like podcast medium
might not be the best like there there
are if if if describing the
metaanalysis line be tough I am not even
going to attempt it's a rainbow done um
like like even if you're looking at them
it it takes you a second to figure out
what's going on with them um but yeah
like in in essence what what they would
predict is that by the time your highest
threshold motor units are being
recruited your other high threshold
motor units have already been recruited
and have been recruited long enough that
they have fatigued enough that your
total capacity to produce force is
already approaching task failure such
that like your highest threshold motor
units never actually ramp all the way up
to like full contraction strength before
you actually fail so like for instance
um like like modeling uh like an
isometric contraction to failure with
50% of 1 RM um they they modeled 120
motor units with motor unit 120 uh
producing having the the capability to
contract with a 100 times more Force
than motor unit one um by the time that
you were reaching failure uh with 50% of
1 RM like your other high threshold
motor units like 80 90 100 105 whatever
have already been recruited and have
already been fatiguing such that by the
time 120 comes in it gets up to about
like
25% um like like 25 5% of its maximal
contraction strength uh before enough
other stuff has fatigued that you just
fail um and like I think that that
is probably relatively likely um to to
occur because like so if it was just if
that was just based on a single modeling
study I'd be like ah who knows like you
know all models are wrong some are
useful how useful is this one I don't
know whatever but um there have been
some other papers so there was a 2020
paper by Miller titled neural Drive is
greater for a higher intensity
contraction then from moderate intensity
contractions performed to fatigue and a
2018 paper by muddle um that was like
largely similar where essentially like
like in Vivo they actually had people um
you know uh do isometric contractions at
different Force targets um to the point
of fatigue and kind of looked at uh like
like using like really sophisticated EMG
decomposition techniques so that instead
of just looking at you know total
amplitudes or or mean power frequency or
whatever like you C you can decompose
and look at each individual motor unit
and look to see kind of like when each
motor unit is recruited like it's
recruitment threshold is kind of like a
proxy for um how high threshold it is
and its firing rate is kind of like axy
for how much tension it's
generating um and what they found is
that like yeah uh you you were seeing
similarly high threshold motor units uh
eventually being recruited before the
point of failure with high versus low
contraction intensities but the like
highest threshold motor units that were
recruited last never actually like
ramped up to the same uh like firing
rates as they did with uh they never
ramped up to as high of firing rates
with lower contraction intensities as
higher contraction intensities which is
kind of like inv Vivo confirmation of
some of those predictions of the poen
model um suggesting that like yeah those
high threshold motor units are recruited
um and they do generate some tension but
they probably don't get particularly
close to generating maximal tension um
and like
to give Chris so the the ah haven't said
his name yet the main proponent of this
model is Chris Beardsley and uh I didn't
come into this podcast to talk
about an individual but yeah like at
this point still not talking but he
has like specifically addressed this
claim before and it's hard to say oh
someone has said something about this uh
so H whatever had to say the name but
yeah so he he has pushed pushed back
against this before um citing the study
by K and colleagues uh arguing that like
the pin model and and this isometric
stuff is not at all relevant to normal
Dynamic training um because in essence
the kind of central fatigue that you
experience with isometric training uh is
way greater and occurs way faster than
the central fatigue you experience with
uh like Ecentric or concentric
contraction
and the the paper he cited and will will
this be linked in the show notes for
people to check out on their own so the
the paper he cited like I I I credit him
for uh addressing this criticism that
I've had previously uh I give him a bit
less credit for selecting the paper he
did to attempt to make this point uh
because it's kind of a mess so in
essence the subjects in the study
completed 100 seconds of maximal
Ecentric concentric and isometric knee
extension reps um and they observed
larger decrements in force and larger
decreases in EMG following the isometric
reps than the Ecentric or concentric
reps and there are like several
methodological things I could point out
about this study um that weren't ideal
for instance they did all three testing
sessions on the same day separated by 10
minutes and after you've done 100
seconds of maximal Ecentric contractions
I don't know that you're going to be
able to do a great job of doing 100
seconds of anything else 10 minutes
later but H whatever um the the big
methodological knit that I need to pick
um is just that they didn't come
anywhere particularly close to like
equating the actual fatigue stimulus in
that the isometric stimulus was
continuous and the Ecentric and
concentric were both intermittent so
essentially with isometric you were
holding the contraction for 100 second
straight and with the Ecentric and
concentric stimulus um like they were
doing it on a isokinetic dyn dynamometer
where like it it doesn't work just like
a knee extension machine would like if
you're doing concentrics like you um
like you have to kick into it going up
but then uh like it the way they had set
up is like it would engage then kind of
like a concentric knee flexion
contraction that they uh basically made
like really light so that they wouldn't
fatigue the hamstrings as well but
basically like they they found that hey
like being all on like Contracting your
quads for as hard as possible for a 100
straight seconds is more fatiguing than
Contracting your quads for one second
and then relaxing for half a second and
then Contracting for a second and
relaxing for half a second like that's
that's what they were doing with the
Ecentric and concentric reps like they
weren't like constantly underload and so
yeah like obviously uh the isometric um
approach caused more fatigue just
because like it was like objectively a
harder thing that they were asking the
subjects to do so it's not really like a
fair representation of the fatigue the
the fatigue that would be induced by
isometric kind of RIT large um and then
the other major problem with the study
is just that like the data is like
clearly bad um and I don't say that in
kind of like a cherry picking like
special pleading Type of Way um like
they observed zero Force decrements
following a 100 seconds of maximal
Ecentric contractions which um you will
never find another paper with those
findings because uh like like that would
that would be God probably because it
was it was 60 degrees per second for the
active part in 120 so it would be oh man
I should have done this beforehand I
think it would have been about 50 to 60
maximal Ecentric reps um yeah people
experience Force decrements after that
100% of the time all individuals all the
time
um again I don't like speaking in
absolutes but if they're observing no
Force decrements they just did a a
really poor job of making sure they were
getting similar levels of effort out of
their subjects for all of the testing
protocols so like H like it's it's a bad
study with bad data um and so
like there there have there have been
like more recent studies that I guess
can be linked in the show notes there
was a 2021 paper by Royer that um I
think did a better job investigating
this thing again Ecentric concentrics
isometrics um they matched according to
the torque time interval to make sure
that the amount of work done in each uh
condition was equated and they found
pretty similar decrements in force and
pretty similar changes in voluntary
activation uh with all three contraction
modes which would suggest that Central
fatigue was probably pretty similar um
with all three contraction modes um and
there was also a paper that Chris could
have cited if he wanted to that would
have made the point that he was trying
to make with the K paper but it is a
better paper um it's by babal in
2006 um I I won't bore you with the
details of it but like you you could
interpret its findings to suggest that
um fatigue generated during isometric
contractions versus concentric
contractions with isometrics it might be
more Central fatigue with concentric it
might be more peripheral so like there
there might be some different fatigue
mechanisms there
um
but that
is ultimately like that still wouldn't
fully kind of get around the predictions
of the poin model um because like I
think I think in in arguing against it
Chris may have not like fully understood
it
honestly like the the thing he pushed
back against was like oh the the poin
model is like predicting um decrements
and firing rates due to Central uh
fatigue but like there's way more
Central fatigue with isometric
contractions than Dynamic contractions
therefore like it wouldn't apply but the
the decrements in um in firing rate due
to fatigue in the poin model are
actually like quite modest
and uh with the example I gave before of
the highest threshold motor unit only
reaching about 25% of its maximum uh
contractile capacity in that simulation
it was predicted to have like to be
unfatigued enough that it would have
been capable of generating up to 95% of
its maximal theoretical Force so like
that just wasn't that that's that's not
a factor like heavily influencing the
interpret of this like with reference to
the model um so yeah like I don't know I
don't think that that is particularly
persuasive and it also I don't think
would make that much of a difference if
there were different fatigue mechanisms
because the highest threshold motor
units in general would also tend to be
the ones that are more metabolically
fatigable so like if that was the thing
like driving the predictions of thep
model which again it's not um like like
differences in kind of like Central
motor Drive affecting um uh like
contraction frequency of uh firing rates
I mean like even if that were the thing
and you wanted to say no no no like
that's not relevant it it is actually
more about peripheral fatigue those
higher threshold motor units do also
just experience faster peripheral
fatigue than lower threshold motor units
do so um it's kind of like Sid stepping
it without like
actually addressing anything but again
like it's also not particularly relevant
here
because man this would be this would be
such better content If people could
actually see the graphs but here's a
here's one question I guess in ESS in
essence like the higher the highest
threshold motor units are predicted to
not reach anywhere particularly close to
maximal uh contraction strength
because those other motor units are are
fatiguing not because the highest
threshold motor units are fatiguing like
super fast gotcha um I I guess one
question I have in terms of the
interpretation of the poin model
specifically to the contraction mode is
more of a like logistical thing that
I've wondered in terms of the influence
of it so if if I recall correctly the
only one of the simulations that reached
near maximal or maximal firing rates for
the highest thresh motor units was the
like the mvic like the 100% of uh the
isometric
torque one thing with Dynamic versus
isometric contractions that I feel like
is potentially important is that
necessarily from a submaximal isometric
Force task you cannot apply maximal
concentric effort yeah and I I wonder if
that I don't really have a point here
other than conceivably in a dynamic task
applying maximal concentric effort would
presumably influence the number of motor
units recruited and ultimately influence
the fatigue Dynamics thereof because
just like you said if anything the
highest threshold motor units would be
the ones that are fatiguing the fastest
um and if they're exposed to fatigue
earlier in a set based on the fact
they're recruited because you're using
maximum concentric effort in a dynamic
task compared to an isometric task I
wonder how that kind of plays out in the
calculus I don't know if you ever kind
of thought about that limitation of the
isometric model I I I have yeah um and I
and I think that what you were saying
does so okay so so just kind of like
first things first um there there are
like absolutely limitations to applying
an isometric model to kind of making
predictions about what would happen
during Dynamic exercise
but I also think that just like the
critique of you can't apply this one to
one um doesn't therefore prove that you
reach maximal tension with high
threshold motor units um it just means
that like the the the evidence against
that idea isn't super strong but uh that
there is no strong evidence
to support the idea that you're reaching
maximal tension with your highest
threshold motor units dur Dynamic
exercise um but then kind of like more
more directly addressing that question
like yeah I I think you're right like so
if if um you're Contracting with maximal
intended force with a 50% of one RM load
instead of just
maintaining uh 50% of MV
with with uh an isometric load like
those those are two different things you
are probably recruiting more total motor
units from the jump with uh the the 50%
of 1 RM uh Dynamic
contractions um and let's just say for
the sake of argument that you are
recruiting your very highest threshold
motor units from the jump like I I kind
of don't think you are but like let's
just assume you are um then I think what
what you're alluding to like fatigue
Dynamics being in play like I think that
would be very relevant because like if
if the principle of orderly recruitment
still applies which like I think it does
if you were actually recruiting those
highest threshold motor units from the
jump they would not be anywhere close to
their maximal firing rate or generating
anywhere close to their maximal tension
um I I mean in part just because like
total contraction speed would still be
very fast because it's the start of a
set with 50% um but yeah like the they
they wouldn't be generating maximal
tension then um and and and like even if
the contraction velocity was slow for
some reason which like I don't know how
it could be but like let's just say
theoretically it was just because the
force demands are so low you would be
getting like maximal force out of your
lower threshold motor units and just
kind of like the amount the the
closeness of each motor unit to its
maximal Enon as you go up um the
recruitment order would would just keep
going down so like even if you were
recruiting that highest threshold motor
unit it would be recruited and it
wouldn't be doing much like it would it
would be at a relatively low tension
relative to its maximal and then if it
stays recruited like it is going to be a
relatively fatigable motor unit like the
the force with which it would need to
contract would need to increase
throughout the set um um like as other
motor units
fatigued and as it is being recruited
and used longer and longer it will
continue to fatigue and so like by the
time other motor units have tapped out
and like it does need to do more it it
would have whether due to Central or
peripheral factors have fatigued enough
that it would be unable to achieve its
like maximal tension one one uh sorry
just to piggy back off that one reason I
kind of believe that there's another
study that I think
I I not a lot of people know about it
but I think it's a really interesting
one in terms of the proximity failure
case is a study by Lim and they
basically had three groups one of them
was 80% of failure one of them was 30%
of failure and then one of them was 30%
of onm which was volume load matched by
manipulating repetitions per set to the
80% of one RM condition and by effect
you have a low load group that I think
if I recall is like at least like 10
reps in reserve and and presumably by
the the model that we've kind of put
forth here that wouldn't even come close
to recruiting the highest thres motor
units then but actually the fiber type
that saw meaningful hypertrophy there
was type two fibers rather than type one
and of course that is confounded by the
fact that potentially type two fibers
just grow more in general but
nonetheless I find that as an
interesting observation to say like in
Dynamic contractions it's at least
plausible that like we're getting
maximum motor unit recuitment maybe a
little bit earlier than we would expect
um which obviously has all the
implications on the fatigue dynamics
that you're talking about so yeah but
but I I think you would also agree that
if those high threshold motor units were
being recruited during the the 30% work
match condition they probably weren't
getting particularly close for sure for
sure yeah I I agree with that to be
clear I just I think that's a to me that
is a data point that is hard to explain
if
if the if the conditions necessary for
the the highest threshhold motor units
to produce hypertrophy only can occur at
the end of the set where we're presuming
that their firing rates are maxed out I
I think that that is basically
implausible if that's the case which I
agree with you that um that that doesn't
really seem to to match up from what I
understand yeah so I I have kind of like
two two things just to kind of like put
a put a bow on this um that that I think
relate to what you're saying
one is that
um actually three things first is just
that uh we we do just kind of take it on
faith that a fiber needs to be recruited
in order to grow um I don't like I I'm
I'm willing to accept that as an
assumption but I'm not actually like
super confident in that assumption one
of the reasons why just has to do with
like it is still kind of an open
question of what the primary mechano
sensors are and um like two
possibilities that have been put forth
are uh like like costamere Associated
mechano sensors and um nuclear
compression as as like that itself being
mechanosensitive and so if those are our
tension sensors um then like the um the
endomysium that's like surrounding all
of the muscle
fibers if a single fiber contracts it is
pulling on the endomysium which is then
like the endomysium pulls on the other
muscle fibers and so if it's like a
threshold of shearing Force needs to be
reached on those camere proteins in
order to change their confirmation to
kind of like kick all of that off I
don't see why it wouldn't be possible
for surrounding fibers to contract
create tension on the connective tissue
Matrix and that tension on the
connective tissue Matrix to create
tension on a costom protein for a fiber
that hasn't been activated like if if
those are like uh some of the important
mechano sensors that would that would at
least open the door for a fiber not
needing to be recruited and generating
active fiber tension of its own in order
for mechanical tension to kick off a
hypertrophy signaling Cascade in that
fiber um and similar with like nuclear
deformation if basically like the muscle
getting a pump uh like creates enough
pressure in the muscle that it
compresses the nucleus again like if if
you generate a pump like that that is
that should be more or less equally
distributed uh for everything under the
epimysium so everything including fibers
that are not recruited so anyway I that
all of which is to say that's kind of
like the the maximal like skeptical
shitthead approach to this like if if
you wanted to be like maximally
skeptical you could like credibly argue
that we don't actually have evidence
that a fiber needs to be recruited in
order to grow because we don't but if we
were still to accept that assumption um
it's also like not obvious to me that a
fiber needs to approach its maximal
tension um in order for
tension
Associated um mechano sensors to be able
to like pick it up and kind of start
that signaling Cascade and one of the
reasons I say that is like largely just
kind of logistical I guess so the the
idea with mechano sensors is that some
sort of force is placed upon them and
that Force being placed upon them
changes the conformation of the protein
such that it can interact with other
proteins like set up a secondary
messenger system phosphorate them like
who who knows whatever and like proteins
are kind of dumb like they they don't
they don't have intelligence like they
they respond to just whatever like
external um stimulus is like placed upon
them and so like if there if there was
some sort of tension sensitive mechanos
sensor that like like let's just say it
need like let's say it's a camir
Associated protein and if uh and if
three Newtons of force are put upon like
three Newtons of shearing Force are put
upon that protein that is sufficient to
change its confirmation such that it can
then phosphorate Downstream proteins and
get things going
um I don't I I am unaware of a mechanism
by which that tension threshold would
change as someone got stronger um and so
like you know if if if it's going like
if it takes like what whatever the
threshold like just X Newtons of force
in order to like actually change the
confirmation of that protein for it to
do what it needs to do that should just
be the same for that protein regardless
of individual and um like that I would
think would equate to a higher
percentage of fiber force in some people
than others and I think that it wouldn't
necessar and I think it would be like
like fiber type and and motor unit
number would be relevant as well um
because like if you have similar meano
sensors in your smaller weaker type 1
fibers as your bigger stronger type two
fibers and the type one fibers are
capable like the your smallest weakest
type one fibers are capable of
Contracting with enough Force to kind of
like trigger that meano sensor it seems
un likely that your biggest strongest
type two fibers would also need to
contract with maximal force in order to
like stimulate that same mechano
sensor um and so yeah like I like just
just just based on the way that like
mechanosensitive proteins work I I don't
see a mechanism by which you would need
to generate maximal fiber tension and as
the maximum tension a fiber can generate
changes that the sensitivity of the
protein to tension would scale one to
one with the changes in capacity to
generate fiber tension um which is which
is just like another reason that I'm
like quite skeptical that you need to
approach Maxim maximal fiber tension in
order to kind of like kick this off or
or even like maximally kick it off you
know um so th those were two things and
then the third thing
um is just that
like I wonder how a lot of this would
relate to type one fiber hypertrophy
just because like low threshold motor
units are recruited all the time and
even for like a low like like for a low
velocity low Force thing your lower your
lowest threshold motor units are
probably being recruited and and being
exposed to something approaching near
maximal ition um and even though we see
less type one fiber hypertrophy than
type two following training we do still
see like pretty robust type one fiber
hypertrophy and I yeah like I I wonder
about that because those fibers should
be getting exposed to their near maximal
tension like pretty frequently and so
like a resistance training stimulus
would seem to be like completely
redundant like the like your your your
five lowest threshold motor units don't
know the difference between a max squat
and like walking up the stairs and so
like why should a resistance training
stimulus cause growth in those fibers um
and I mean I think that it is because
there's a lot of other biological
perturbations associated with a
resistance training stimulus and that
it's not just all about tension but if
it is if it is all about tension like
that's that's a head scrp
you
know Josh anything to say Chief before I
take us into uh some practical
wrap-ups no I don't I don't think I
have anything directly to add on that um
I know that Lim paper kind of always
scratched their heads about Zach that
you up and Greg you brought up some uh
some
conceptual kind of framing to to uh a
similar issue we've thought of and I and
I
mentioned I mentioned there was a time
period where we were pretty far away
from any sort of effective reps model
and kind of our our handwavy motor unit
physiology explanation was like man why
why would the most fatigable muscle
fibers require the most fatigue in the
set to
experience maximum tension and then I
think you added a few layers for me to
chew on in terms of you
know
is is the tension actually what's what's
driving it in all cases right as as
we've talked about yeah throughout so I
think that was good I'm probably gonna
have to to listen to it
back think about it some more yeah no
applying counterfactuals in those
examples I think is just a listener to
take away from any kind of model that's
been put forward I think applying
counterfactuals to that and like testing
those on the evidence that those would
be supported with is a good practice um
for kind of all things like that but but
yeah so we've come a long way we've come
you know from humble beginnings all the
way through the the The Valleys of
Despair um and now we're you know we're
we're back on the other side of this
conversation back on Sunshine Road um
and Greg's goingon to give us his his
kind of opinions and we can kind of talk
through this on all
right clearly
we don't know everything but as we've
said a few times throughout this
conversation you do have to eventually
train you have to write down your best
guess your best approximation of all
these mechanisms and put something down
on a training program and so ultimately
the question here is given this
uncertainty given these um multiple
inputs to the kind of the mechanistic
underpinnings that eventually play out
in the longitudinal evidence that we
have and ultimately the meta regression
was the the summary
of if I'm to ask you given all that data
and your practical experience kind of
you're performing you know a couple sets
let's say four for a multi-joint
exercise on average on average on the
muscle groups things like that I'm
pinning your arm down and making you
give on average kind of recommendations
and and you're not allowed to put on
your context hat here too much kind of
what what does the r look like for those
kind of uh four sets on a multijoint
exercise when purch Fe is the goal for
let's say the average listener you know
been training for you know five years or
so looking to kind of get that that
second sprad of progress as they
approach um kind of the advanced
status if if I'm doing four
sets either e either just taking
everything to failure or leaving like
two to four R for the first three sets
and taking the last one to
failure okay cool and so is that
dependent on so I know I know you're
someone who cares about strength I'm
specifically talking about this case
throw that out the window you don't care
but it's a multi-joint exercise for
hyper Fe does that change the answer at
all just the extra piece of context it
may not I'm just double checking um the
the the exercise affects it more than
anything else um cool just kind of like
how safe do I feel going to failure and
also like how much does a set to failure
me up yep uh and like what load am
I training with like for for instance if
it's
like leg press and I'm doing sets of 25
I'm not doing four sets to failure are
you kidding me like I I myself and
throw up and then like set three and
four aren't happening um but if it's
like binge press and I have a spotter I
trust like I'm taking all of those sets
to failure and like I'm not even
thinking about it cool okay so so
underlying
that I'm assuming at least to some
capacity although the degree to which
this is the case is obviously up for
interpretation you believe there is some
sort of additional Roi that comes from
those last couple reps up to failure is
that an accurate
statement um you know I think the
the the thing making a difference for me
there is that it's four sets um if it
was like six or eight I'd probably say
like two or three um but I I do I do
think like I'm not going to reduce
everything to tension but I do think
just like the global magnitude of the
stimulus is relevant yeah and if you're
getting if you're getting four sets and
that's it I think that it's relatively
unlikely that you're going to like the
the stimulus that you can cause is going
to like exceed your ability to
productively adapt to it and so I just
kind of think like well maximize the
stimulus you know yeah and all else
being equal going to failure will give
you a larger stimulus than not perfect
okay that that makes perfect sense and
so I'm assuming for the single joint
exercise given what you just kind of
mentioned basically The Balancing Act of
the stimulus that presumably you know is
to some degree maximize it failure
you're balancing that with your ability
to maintain that quality of work over a
session for a single joint exercise per
four that's probably taken that a of
failure as well or almost always no
question no question yeah there we go if
I meet someone that says that they do
bicep curls with three R it is on site
like get get out of the gym you don't
there it is there it is folks that's the
that's the uh clip it clip it right
there there it is um yeah no I I I think
from a conceptual standpoint I think I
agree I think about this as you know we
kind of have the two relationships and
on an individual LEL level the the
optimization game you're trying to kind
of play out is theoretically we assume
the stimulus is maximized towards
failure but we want the quality of the
entire session to be as high as possible
and so if that is if that is a concern
in the organization of training that you
have exercise section loading range how
many sets you're doing for the total
session Etc then the proximity failure
is manipulated to kind of account for
that and that's I think we're in total
agreement there Josh you have anything
to add on that
one um I do think pacing is a thing um
and that sometimes drives me
to like the r side of things staying a
little bit shy of failure um I I do
think a primary variable here is kind of
like the the question was was framed in
you know with with the constraints of of
four sets you know where you stopping um
and that I think that leads nicely into
into the next question um which is
something we're we hopefully have some
go for yes we'll have some experimental
insight into this as soon as I sit down
and analyze like 250
ultrasound images um but okay let's say
you have the the opportunity to kind of
prioritize one or one or two or sorry
one of these variables right training
volume so so number of sets um or
proximated to failure um wh which of
those are you kind of biasing and
perhaps a reasonable example here is
like three or four sets all the way to
failure or are you going
to you know bump up that R and add some
sets um or is that kind of a pick your
poison in your
view uh man I'm I'm going to give a
copout answer here um which is that that
I I think that there's like pretty big
interindividual differences in terms of
like whether people respond to more of
an intensity stimulus or a volume
stimulus like I I've I've known so many
people who just swear that like high
volume is the best for them and they
tried lower volume closer to failure and
it did did nothing and I've known so
many people who've said the exact
opposite that like they spun their
wheels with high volume and like cutting
it way back and like going closer to
failure like that very reliably produces
gains for them and like I don't think
any of them are lying or misinterpreting
their experience I I think that it's
true and that some people do just
respond better to more of an intensity
stimulus and some people do just respond
better to more of a volume stimulus and
I'm not totally sure why um but if
you're asking me personally um I'm I'm
going to failure um and then not scaling
weekly volume because high volume beats
the out of me um like I I would I
would rather take like three sets where
I meet God near the end of them uh on
every one than 12 sets where I have like
five reps in reserve every day of the
week yeah see I feel the I feel almost
the complete opposite um not necessarily
five R but uh you know I've specifically
once we kind of had these these
regressions on my hand I was like okay I
see I see where this is going to go in
terms of a lot of folks interpretations
and and applications so I spent a a few
months doing almost everything to to
momentary failure um I don't think it
went that well uh that that did come
with a a reduction in in volume but then
when I kind of came back to to a little
bit more of a moderate approach
everything seemed to to get going again
um but yeah I I I do think there
are that that definitely aligns with my
observations as well that some folks um
some folks per perhaps it's just a
tolerance of of failure um or I guess it
could be a tolerance of the additional
sets right uh because those are kind of
different stimuli at least to some
degree and I'm starting to think of of
hypertrophy training in terms of working
backwards
from
what's desirable and to me what's
desirable is high volumes and all the
way to
failure and then you kind of work within
practical constraints from there I.E is
this going to absolutely smoke you are
you going to have like you know your
you're you're training quads and then
hamstrings are you going to have
absolutely zero mental energy left for
hamstrings that sort of thing um so
perhaps it's it's kind of like these
indirect factors not true how you
respond in isolation to the stimulus but
instead uh some of those Downstream
effects in terms of you know what you
can uh cram in within a a training block
for example yeah know I I I I agree with
that very
strongly nice Zach sweet um I'm gonna
skip the long muscle length one I think
that's yeah I think yeah I'm going skip
that one um last one here Greg be
respectful of your time
um I can't say that anymore yeah I can't
say that anymore um yeah that's just
that's that was a Miss um okay so not
being respectful of your time being very
selfish
um how so let's say let's say you are
you know a lifter in your case where for
whatever reason um
tolerating like high volumes seems to
just not be the thing um but let's say
you're on the opposite of the spectrum
where it's proximity fil that seems to
be the problem or not problem but that's
the variable you don't tolerate is there
anything you've seen in your experience
that has been useful in improving your
ability to tolerate that you know type
of training such that you're improving
your tolerance capacity and can kind of
improve the amount of training under the
curve that you can kind of productively
um handle
oh man I think I think it depends on the
reason for it um like I I think I think
some people to struggle with tolerating
training close to failure simply due to
lack of experience and for
them for a couple weeks week one's going
to suck by week three it'll be fine um
some people
it's it's it's kind of just a matter of
like conditioning like it's hard to
trained to failure and uh you know you
get one like really hard set in and you
just you just have nothing in the tank
like it you lay on the ground for five
minutes and then after five minutes
you're still only like 30% of the way
recovered um for those folks I kind of
think that either like doing doing some
short rest interval stuff or high rep
stuff um or honestly just going for a
run like just just something to
help improve conditioning a little bit
if that's like the the constraint can
help um and then for for some folks and
like I'm not sure the cause of this um
but just like they go all the way to
failure and their joints just really
dislike them and that's the case whether
it's heavy loads whether it's light
loads like they just need to keep a
couple reps in the T feeling good um
maybe that's something they could work
out with a physical therapist but I
haven't found a approach to just like
prescribing normal training that that
gets them out of the woods like maybe
changing exercise selection could help a
little bit if there's like certain
things that bother whatever joint it is
but I don't know I I I sort of wonder if
that might just be related to
inflammation and like really like really
like putting a lot of stress on it um
especially under conditions of like
neuromuscular fatigue where like your
joint mechanics may change slightly like
like that that might just not be good
for them and you're not really going to
get them to a point where going to
failure feels
good man I think we're there fellas Josh
anything else to add before you get us
out of here yeah I I think we can
quickly mention some some stuff we're
working on and and that other folks are
working on to uh get some further
insight into this and in an applied
sense and you know probably have again
more questions and answers um we as I
alluded to a little bit ago
basically in some of the final stages of
comparing like a momentary failure with
lower set volume sort of condition to a
higher set volume non-failure condition
um that's a within subject study that
that we have a a lot of of uh a lot of
measurement sites on so that's kind of
the the bottleneck right now is getting
all those analyzed um I'm I'm really
excited to see
that hey well that'll that'll light a
fire under my butt because kind of the
second thing that we're also working on
that's kind of been the the priority
more so than than getting that out the
door is similar meta aggressions on the
training volume research for both
strength and hypertrophy um that's been
kind of all of 23 thing for uh for
myself Jake and Zach here um so that's
also in the final stages so we'll kind
of have some insights into what that
dose response looks like and then lastly
uh and and I think Zach you're you're
directly involved in this is Martin
rafalo who we've mentioned a couple
times here does awesome work um he's in
Australia right or yeah Australia yeah
Australia um his PhD thesis
comparing momentary failure training to
I think it's two R training one to two R
yeah it's it'll it'll be the best
training study on this topic in my
opinion yeah yeah which
uh you know a big limitation of the met
aggressions or or of yeah of the Met
aggression that we've been talking about
is is a lot of the studies were
estimated in terms of R um whereas he's
doing an excellent job of controlling R
in very wellt trained folks I'm always
surprised by how wellt trained his his
samples are uh he he went I yeah just to
give him a little bit of credit the the
stud is just extremely well done like he
went above and beyond for a lot of
different things the way he controlled
nutrition like just it's a really really
well done project and I hope he yeah he
should be proud of what he's done I'm
excited for him to get it out there it's
cool yeah and then lastly I'll throw out
your your dissertation as well Zach
which isn't directly like a a volume
approximated failure study but it is
kind of
effectively uh a volume study with
also so yeah lot lots of stuff to uh to
hopefully add some insights here um and
with that Greg we are I I want you to
talk for about two and a half minutes so
we get to the 4 Hour
[Laughter]
Mark um but if you have any closing
remarks anything you want to direct
folks towards we of course link Stronger
by science below um but if there's
anything else you want to kind of Point
people
towards here's here's your shot for the
four people listening at this point
uh sounds good um yeah I don't have much
else but I am very very comfortable with
stalling because I understand how
satisfying it would be to hit the 4our
mark um and I'm I'm willing and and able
to to accommodate you guys there
um just just for
some on to close things out
I always think that it's interesting to
think a little bit about how much uh
human culture owns to the development of
beer and yogurt um and cheese so one of
the things you don't really think about
with like ancient prehistory is that
humans uh Homo sapiens sa Hunter gathers
that were arranged in small tribal bands
um and and there was no
real civilization so when when we say
civilization we talk about we're
referring to a large enough
conglomeration of people that folks who
aren't directly blood kin um can be in
contact with each other uh frequently
enough and long enough to develop an
understanding of of the US just outside
of familial ties and so to do that you
need to be able to cram enough people
into a small enough uh uh situation
where where you can facilitate that and
so first you needed the Advent of
Agriculture obviously you can't have
millions of people in a hunter gatherer
tribe that much is obvious then after
you have
agriculture like humans need something
like five acres of arable land a piece
to be able to
support family like that that still
requires people to be fairly spread out
so
uh essentially you needed the Advent of
cities and for the Advent of cities you
needed to have productive enough
agriculture to get calories into the
city uh where people aren't doing
agriculture but you needed to be able to
do that year round very
reliably uh problem with with crops is
and they and they go bad and so one of
the like fundamental incredibly
important things for the develop of
human civilization was the Advent of
fermentation because with fermentation
now instead of calories essentially
having like a very finite very short
shelf life where you have to consume
them or they start rotting going bad
whatever now after a harvest
or C caving season where you can like
milk your goats and whatnot it was more
goats than cows back then